comme le débat précédent le débat sera
organisé en deux parties nous
commencerons par une table ronde en
présence de personnalité invitée d'une
durée d'à peu près une heure puis nous
procéderons après avoir entendu une
intervention luminaire du gouvernement à
une nouvelle séquence de
questions-réponses d'une durée d'une
heure également la durée des questions
et les réponses sera limitée à deux
minutes sans droit de réplique pour la
première phase du débat je souhaite la
bienvenue à Monsieur Didier kerscioli
secrétaire général de la mutualité
fonction publique Madame Catherine
Perret secrétaire confédéral de la
Confédération générale du travail en
charge des questions de formation
professionnelle
non retraite très bien je vous remercie
je rectifie et enfin Monsieur martial
trans membre de la direction de l'Union
des fédérations des fonctions publiques
et assimilées Confédération française
démocratique du travail de la fonction
publique c'est bien ça je vous remercie
je vais donc maintenant donner la parole
à chacun de nos invités pour une durée
donc d'environ cinq minutes la parole
est à Monsieur Didier kerscioli
merci merci madame la Présidente bonsoir
mesdames messieurs les députés la
Mutualité fonctionne publique est
toujours ravie de pouvoir échanger avec
les élus de la République et je vais
articuler mon propos autour de 5 points
une présentation très rapide de la
mutualité fonction publique quelques
mots sur l'observatoire mutualité
fonction publique Aris interactive sur
les fragilités des agents publics la
réforme de la protection sociale
complémentaire des agents publics et je
vais également exprimer quelques
craintes quelques risques majeurs et
inquiétudes que nous avons par rapport à
cette réforme et puis quelques mots de
conclusion alors la Mutualité fonctionne
publique MFP est une fédération qui
regroupe 18 mutuelles de la Fonction
publique qui protègent 6,5 millions
d'agents publics et leurs familles c'est
depuis plus de 75 ans que la MFP protège
et défend les intérêts les intérêts des
agents publics pour leur protection
sociale leurs droits sociaux avec une
app solidaire et globale pour les actifs
et les retraités ainsi l'amfp a une
entière légitimité en tant qu'acteur une
entière légitimité dans ces missions de
défense des droits sociaux des agents
publics et également une légitimité
d'expertise avec sa troisième édition de
l'Observatoire des fragilités des agents
publics publiés pour la dernière fin
2000 2022 3 choses à retenir de cette
dernière édition de l'Observatoire la
première c'est que 84% des agents
publics affichent une satisfaction
élevée quant à leur activité
professionnelle mais ce ne sont que 40%
d'entre eux qui s'interrogent au fil des
années
envie de rester dans le service public
40% qui s'interrogent au fil des années
qui passent la deuxième la deuxième
chose à retenir relève de l'influence du
travail sur la santé 30% des agents
publics estiment que leur travail exerce
une influence négative sur leur santé et
52% des agents considèrent que le
travail aura à l'avenir encore davantage
d'influence négatives sur leur sur leur
santé et la troisième la troisième chose
à retenir et que la santé concerne la
santé mentale des agents les risques
liés à la santé mentale est en forte
augmentation dans les dans les items
notamment en particulier chez les agents
de la fonction publique hospitalière qui
eux sont très exposés à la fatigue au
stress à la pénibilité physique ainsi si
les agents publics ne sont pas en bonne
santé c'est tout le service public qui
n'est pas en bonne santé j'en viens
maintenant à la réforme de la protection
sociale complémentaire des
fonctionnaires PSC gouvernement a
légiférer il y a exactement deux ans par
ordonnance pour la PSC des agents
publics la tension est bien sûr louable
il nous en félicitons puisque c'est une
participation de l'État employeur à
hauteur de 50% pour la protection
sociale des agents publics ce qui
devient symétrique par rapport au
secteur du privé dont avec la mise en
place de Lagny en 2016 c'est depuis
longtemps que nous réclamons cela les
textes réglementaires
arrivent mais sont
nos concrétisent pas l'ambition affichée
la réalité est bien plus complexe qu'on
qu'on et l'on peut venir à se demander
si c'est une bonne réforme ainsi
tout d'abord sur le volet de la
prévoyance l'incapacité l'invalidité la
dépendance et la perte d'autonomie avec
la mise en place d'une réforme pas
simplement une réforme mais en fait
trois réformes puisque
il y a une adaptation aux trois versants
aux trois versants de la fonction
publique et ses spécificités de chacune
de ces de chacun de ces versants à la
fonction publique d'État quelque part à
cette réforme sur le volet prévoyance
est à l'arrêt
à la fonction PICT territoriale c'est
une réforme actuellement encore
inaboutie avec une participation
possible mais seulement de 20% sur le
volet prévoyance à la fonction publique
hospitalière aucune réforme est encore
pour l'instant engagée aucune discussion
en étant engagée ainsi je donnais un
exemple sur un risque comme la
dépendance qui qui en serait exclu
augmenterait si quelqu'un avait une
rente dépendance aujourd'hui de 500
euros mensuel avec une cotisation
d'origine de 20 euros par mois et bien
cette cotisation s'en verrait multipliée
par 9 voir 10 amenant la cotisation de
180 et 200 euros par mois c'est
aujourd'hui 3 millions de fonctionnaires
qui sont couverts par ce risque
avec cette cotisation de 20 euros qui se
verrait
avoir subir une régression une
régression de leur couverture
sur le volet de la santé aussi on peut
s'étonner que l'on évoque les grandes
orientations de santé publique avec le
virage du préventif mais il y a aucune
aucune rien de prévu en termes de
financement de prévention
tout comme pour la campagnement social
ou c'est une diminution de 4 à 6 fois
alors
l'inquiétude est aussi en termes
sociales pour les pour les pour les
mutuelles aujourd'hui si je donne un
exemple s'il y a pas d'appel d'offres
réussie donc c'est 10 000 agents par
exemple pour la MGEN qui risque de se
retrouver en risque de perte d'emploi et
puis simplement pour terminer pour
conclure
cette réforme joue un rôle majeur sur
l'acte réactivité de la fonction
publique elle est liée à la réforme des
retraites mais aussi au bien-être au
travail elle doit être améliorée et pour
avoir une réforme ambitieuse et la santé
n'est pas un produit comme les autres et
ne pas oublier que les agents public S
qui sont en bonne santé c'est un service
en bonne santé un service public en
bonne santé au service du public merci
votre attention c'est moi qui vous
remercie la parole est à Madame
Catherine Perret
bonjour à toutes et tous je vais sans
doute centrer mon intervention sur la
question des retraites même si bien
évidemment c'est un tout mon collègue
l'a dit on en parle de protection
sociale dans son ensemble et que on peut
revenir dans la série de questions sur
la protection sociale complémentaire qui
a été négocié et qui est en cours de
négociation pour la partie Providence
mais vous dire aussi qu'elle a CGT nous
portons un projet de sécurité sociale
intégrale et donc qui place en fait la
sécurité sociale au centre de l'ensemble
des risques de la naissance jusqu'à la
mort et qui réserve la comment dire le
rôle des mutuelles aux questions de
prévention question de santé publique
donc évidemment on peut revenir sur ces
questions là dans la série des questions
donc quelques éléments sur les enjeux de
la réforme en cours sur la fonction
publique d'abord en préalable je
voudrais vous dire que même si depuis
plusieurs semaines
on vous entendez
un une communication du gouvernement
autour d'une réforme paramétrique pour
nous en fait c'est pas une réforme
paramétrique c'est bien une réforme
systémique que ce projet de loi que vous
avez à débattre dans l'hémicycle à
partir du moment où c'est un projet qui
modifie complètement l'organisation des
différents systèmes et régimes de
retraite existants en France et au cœur
évidemment il y a le système régime de
la fonction publique un certain nombre
de régimes spéciaux sont déjà dans le
collimateur du gouvernement et même si
pour le moment une partie de la survie
du régime la fonction publique n'est pas
n'est pas évoqué même si le taxi arrive
au Sénat porte quand même un article
supplémentaire autour de ce rapport en
matière de système universel bien
évidemment on efface une volonté de
faire disparaître tous les régimes
spécifiques et en cela c'est bien une
réforme systémique c'est donc une
réforme qui veut
basculer l'ensemble des agents des trois
versants de la fonction publique à terme
dans le régime général du privé pour
quelle raison
apparemment pas beaucoup de réseau je
dirais
argumenter pas beaucoup de raisons
financières à cela puisque il n'y a
aucune raison justement de faire
disparaître un régime de la fonction
publique qui est particulièrement bien
financé bien géré et dont le seul
problème est lié au manque d'emploi dans
le secteur de la fonction publique tout
le monde est dans vos circonscriptions
respectives vous le savez bien tout le
monde cherche des soignants tout le
monde cherche des enseignants tout le
monde cherche des fonctionnaires pour
répondre aux besoins de la population et
il suffirait de recruter recruter 300
000 agents de la fonction publique de
l'État
et 300 000 soignants dans la fonction
hospitalière pour couvrir les 13
milliards annoncés de déficit par le
gouvernement qui nécessiterait cette
réforme aussi brutale donc la question
de l'emploi dans la fonction publique et
aussi majeur évidemment dans la question
du financement de l'équilibre et de ce
qu'on veut faire de nos retraites demain
pas de pas de conséquences non plus en
matière de fonction publique sur les
questions d'emploi puisque
on le gouvernement dit souvent
reculer l'âge de départ à la retraite à
64 ans ça va permettre de forcer les
seniors à travailler plus longtemps
puisque évidemment il y a une vraie
épine dans le pied du ministre qui vient
de nous précéder puisque plus de 60% des
salariés ne sont plus en l'emploi on
emploie à l'âge légal aujourd'hui or du
point de vue de la fonction publique il
n'y a pas ce problème là puisque au
contraire
tout le monde est en emploi jusqu'à
l'âge légal et la moyenne d'âge de
sortie des fonctionnaires globalement et
déjà de 64 ans alors vous allez me dire
pourquoi vous êtes dans la rue et
pourquoi vous refusez cette réforme et
bien parce que évidemment ils sont
conduits à aller jusqu'à 64 ans parce
que c'est la conséquence des réformes
régressives précédents depuis 2003 qui
ont conduit à la fois reculer l'âge
légal mais surtout imposer de plus en
plus de trimestres pour obtenir un taux
plein et permettre aux personnes de
partir à la retraite c'est pourquoi le
deuxième vrai la deuxième vraie raison
de cette réforme qui touche tout le
monde mais en particulier les
fonctionnaires c'est pas d'allonger là
je départ c'est de baisser plus
rapidement le niveau des pensions des
pensions des fonctionnaires comme des
salariés du secteur privé c'est de là
encore une fois c'est totalement
documenté
le le
double effet de reculer l'âge légal et
d'imposer une un allongement du nombre
de trimestres pour obtenir un taux plein
c'est une méthode qui accélère encore
plus la baisse des pensions et qui
accélère donc les économies que le
gouvernement veut faire sur le dos des
fonctionnaires deuxième élément et
deuxième raison qui doit attirer votre
attention c'est la question on vient
d'en parler dans le premier débat la
question des départs anticipés là encore
les enjeux de la réforme des retraites
en matière de fonction publique se
posent sur la question de l'existence
dans par répertoire de métier de droit
et à des départs anticipés que le
gouvernement veut voir disparaître je
crois que le ministre du travail était
très clair précédemment il ne veut plus
de droit collectifs il ne veut plus de
droit lié au travail il veut au métier
exercé il veut individualiser des
dispositifs et tous les régimes spéciaux
qui veut faire disparaître comme celui
de la fonction publique sont dotés
justement de droits collectifs qui
permettent à des corps de métiers par
l'exercice à la fois de mission
d'intérêt de services publics et des
expositions à des situations pénibles
dans le travail qui peuvent être très
diverses j'insiste sur l'exercice des
missions de service public ce qu'on
n'est pas obligé de travailler jour et
nuit pour exercer des situations de
travail pénibles il suffit par exemple
d'être au service de l'intérêt général
quand on nous appelle par exemple
quand il y a une tempête et que ce sont
les agents des services publics qui
sortent pour dégager les routes et pour
rendre service à la population ça ce
sont des exercices de mission publique
et c'est très pénible et pour nous ça
vaut évidemment le droit par corps de
métier à avoir la possibilité de partir
en départ anticipé autrement dit
réversible
autrement dit les enjeux de la fonction
publique sont devant nous bien
évidemment et alors qu'on devrait
s'inspirer de ce régime pour généraliser
des droits notamment en matière de
pénibilité à l'ensemble des salariés du
privé et bien le gouvernement fait tout
le contraire et nous allons évidemment
le 7 mars
démontrer que nous allons faire échouer
cette réforme des retraites
merci la parole est à Monsieur martial
crans
députés
donc je représente la CFDT fonction
publique et les 10 fédérations qui
couvrent les 5,2 millions d'agents
publics que compte notre pays alors sur
les retraites évidemment la CFDT est
pleinement mobilisée sur le dossier ça
ne vous aura pas échappé
nous sommes mobilisés pour rejeter le
projet du gouvernement tel qu'il est
présenté aujourd'hui tel qu'il a été
discuté à l'Assemblée nationale tel
qu'il va être maintenant discutée au
Sénat elle a mesure phare de ce projet
le report à 64 ans de l'âge d'ouverture
des droits évidemment la mesure sur
laquelle nous sommes les plus hostiles
la réforme pour nous est complètement
injuste à la CFDT elle est inéquitable
notamment vis-à-vis des femmes des
carrières longues qui sont pénalisés les
parcours hachés on a eu le débat tout à
l'heure autour de la pénibilité vous
avez posé beaucoup de questions au
ministre du soft les réponses qu'on a
entendu depuis les étages ne nous ont
pas évidemment plus de convaincus
on dit que ce mouvement aussi a le
soutient de l'opinion publique autour de
60-70% des citoyens français
n'approuvent pas cette réforme on a
aussi nous pour nous la conviction qu'il
n'y avait pas une urgence financière
telle que ces mesures devaient être
prises immédiatement et aussi
brutalement avec notamment la
l'accélération de la réforme Touraine
on a fait la démonstration de la dignité
et de la bonne tenue des manifestations
dans la rue
on comprend pas que le gouvernement
n'entende pas
qu'il fasse la sourde oreille à toutes
ces mobilisations
dans ce qu'on pourrait presque appeler
un déni de démocratie
on est vraiment inquiet sur la manière
dont va pouvoir se prolonger se face à
face si jamais il n'y avait pas de
bouger au niveau du gouvernement en tout
cas le 7 mars sera une journée de pleine
mobilisation des citoyens dans les rues
pour montrer la détermination donc de
l'ensemble des grandes majorité des
Français à rejeté la réforme sur les
fonctions publiques je vais pas
reprendre ce qu'a dit ma camarade de la
CGT sur l'emploi notamment
on a eu les éléments quand même sur
quelques petits bougies sur les
fonctions publiques qui ne gomme pas
évidemment le l'impression générale
qu'on en a sur l'ensemble du projet
on l'a pointé notamment la pénibilité en
dehors des catégories actives dans la
fonction publique
on a des agents publics qui sont soumis
à la pénibilité mais qui n'étant pas en
catégorie active nous n'aurons aucune
aucune prise en compte on a pointé tout
à l'heure je l'ai entendu la question
des contractuels dans la fonction
publique donc tout ça fait que
la réforme en l'état les choses n'est
pas n'est pas satisfaisante du tout sur
la protection sociale complémentaire je
me permettrai aussi de dire quelques
mots d'abord on a considéré nous à la
CFDT et que c'était une avancée
intéressante voir historique pour les
agents le fait que les employeurs
publics contribuent maintenant au
financement de la protection sociale
complémentaire de leurs agents comme
c'est le cas dans le privé
on a aussi fortement apprécié que cette
évolution soit issue d'une négociation
au sens de l'ordonnance du mois de
février 2021 dans les fonctions
publiques avec la possibilité maintenant
de conclure des accords majoritaires
maintenant ce qu'on regrette c'est que
les trois versants n'avancent pas la
même vitesse il y a des calendriers des
échéances qui sont distincts on aimerait
bien que les choses avancent assez
rapidement et au même rythme pour
l'ensemble des agents publics dans les
trois versants
on aimerait aussi sur la prévoyance
obtenir un accord qui ressemble en tout
cas qui soit de même nature que celui
qu'on avait conclu en janvier 2022 sur
la partie santé en tant qu'en tout cas
dans la partie état et comme l'a dit ce
garcioli c'est ça les choses n'avancent
pas bien vite aujourd'hui sur la
prévoyance on est assez inquiet sur sur
le déroulé des négociations qui sont en
cours on a le sentiment que les choses
sont un peu figées actuellement et les
échéances se rapprochent à vitesse grand
V puisque au 1er janvier 2024 les
nouveaux enfin dans certains cas les
nouveaux systèmes vont devoir se mettre
en place donc on est assez inquiet
là-dessus
la prévoyance donc ces trois supports
importants le capital décès l'incapacité
à l'invalidité sur l'invalidité je vais
faire un petit focus
c'est aujourd'hui dans la fonction
publique la mise en retraite d'office
pour des agents qui se retrouvent du
coup privés de de droits supplémentaires
pour accueillir acquérir pour leur futur
retraite on souhaite un système
totalement modifié je pense que c'est un
sujet important qu'il faudra traiter
alors on nous a dit que ce sujet de
l'invalidité était dans le dossier de la
PSC pas dans celui des retraites donc on
aimerait bien que il soit traité avec le
ministre Stanislas Guérini
on est très fortement aussi intéressé à
la CFDT sur une une dimension statutaire
de la prévoyance donc tout ce qui est
garanti par le par le statut des agents
publics dans les lois qui le régisse
donc l'amélioration de ces conditions
statutaires passent par pour nous enfin
fait partie de d'une avancée à obtenir
et la partie complémentaire sera
évidemment à discuter avec les
opérateurs qui qui prendront le relais à
ce moment-là donc voilà et il y a un
dernier point je m'arrêterai là c'est la
question de la dépendance qui n'est pas
du tout dans le champ de la négociation
mais qui pour nous revient un caractère
très très important dans la mesure où
effectivement
les problèmes se posent de plus en plus
et vous le constatez évidemment
quotidiennement dans vos dans vos
circonscriptions je pense voilà pour
l'instant
je vous remercie tous les trois pour vos
interventions et maintenant nous en
venons aux questions j'invite tous ceux
qui souhaitent intervenir dans la table
ronde à s'inscrire auprès de la
direction de séance 6e à gauche chaque
question sera immédiatement suivie de la
réponse pour que le débat le souhaite le
plus fluide possible la première
question est posée par Monsieur Pierre
dareville du groupe GDR du peste qui
était l'initiative de ce débat
merci madame la Présidente je voudrais
naturellement remercier nos trois
invités d'avoir accepté de participer à
cet échange
et commencer par une question sur la
protection sociale complémentaire
est-ce que vous vous pourriez nous
préciser d'après vous ce qui devrait
figurer à tout prix dans les critères
d'appel d'offres quelles sont les
critères qui vous sembleraient les plus
déterminants à faire figurer dans
dans le dans les appels d'offres et
est-ce que finalement on n'insiste pas à
une évolution du rôle des mutuelles à
travers cette réforme qui est me
proposer
j'ajoute que selon mes informations le
ministère se ferait assister d'un
cabinet de conseils sur la négociation
j'aimerais si c'est le cas que vous nous
disiez ce que vous en savez
sur la question
ensuite de
la prévoyance et du financement de la
prévention je pense que ça fait partie
des critères que vous voulez évoquer je
serais intéressé par des précisions
également ainsi que sur l'invalidité qui
a été évoqué par Martial krance qui est
un sujet que nous avons évoqué dans la
table ronde précédente et qui mérite
sans doute aussi d'être posé de manière
singulière à la fonction publique sur le
versant des retraites est-ce que vous
pourriez nous en dire un peu plus sur
l'évolution de la prise en compte de la
pénibilité dans la fonction publique
première question
sur les évolutions nécessaires sans
doute et les évolutions qui ont eu lieu
dans un beau bon ou dans un mauvais sens
et la deuxième chose est-ce que vous
pourriez nous dire quels sont les effets
de la réforme de la fonction publique
sur la construction du droit à la
retraite j'ai vu qu'il y avait une
évolution par exemple
progression du nombre de vacataires dans
la fonction publique par rapport au
nombre de titulaires
quels sont effectivement les effets que
ça peut avoir que l'emploi public la
structure de l'emploi public peut avoir
sur la la construction du du droit à la
retraite du et du système de retraite
merci
je vous remercie alors qu'il souhaite
répondre
Monsieur kersuli Merci monsieur le
député alors je vais répondre à
certaines de
vos questions alors sur les
parliez de la protection sociale
complémentaire des fonctionnaires et
demander de préciser les critères et
qu'elle serait ceux qui sont
déterminants aujourd'hui les mutuelles
historiques de la fonction publique qui
protège des agents publics depuis près
de 75 ans sont ont des valeurs sur la
solidarité la solidarité
intergénérationnelle la solidarité entre
actif retraitée ce sont des éléments qui
permettent de faire contribuer chacun
chacune au bénéfice de ceux qui sont
dans le dans le besoin demain avec la
réforme de la protection sociale
complémentaire telle qu'elle est
aujourd'hui dessinée on a une
segmentation qui qui se fait de de
factures entre les retraités et les
actifs ce qui rend les périmètres
beaucoup plus restreint et c'est pour ça
que dans dans mes propos de départ
j'avais pris l'exemple de la dépendance
mais on pourrait faire la même chose
avec d'autres sujets comme la prévention
si c'est pas si c'est c'est ces éléments
là ne sont pas inclus dans la protection
sociale et bien on déjà ils sont à
c'est chaque individu qui devra se les
offrir mais en même temps quand il y a
pas mutualisation et sur un utilisation
sur un sur un périmètre beaucoup plus
restreint et bien les coûts pour
s'offrir cette mutuation à couverture
égale sont beaucoup plus importants et
et ça forcément des des effets après
cette protection sociale en termes de
prévoyance si elle n'est pas incluse
dans dans l'offre et dans l'appel
d'offres en général avec une proposition
uniquement individuelle où chacun de
façon facultative de vin souffrir et ben
ça veut dire que à ce moment-là ça
devient pour beaucoup d'agents carrément
inaccessibles et pour par rapport à ce
qui existe aujourd'hui en tous les cas
si je prends toujours l'exemple de la
dépendance c'est bien pour 3 millions de
de fonctionnaires aujourd'hui qu'il y
aura une régression des droits notamment
sur la dépendance
merci
madame Perret vous souhaitez compléter
je sais pas si on a le temps mais dire
quand même qu'on regrette enfin c'est un
accord unanime la protection sociale
complémentaire de la fonction publique
donc on est tous solidaire de cet accord
mais je crois qu'on est tous aussi à
regretter le fait qu'on a pas pu aboutir
dans la négociation sur une prise en
compte justement d'un droit ouvert aux
actifs comme au retraité parce que ça
renvoie justement en partie à la
question que vous posiez sur la question
de l'avenir du statut de la fonction
publique quand on est à Jean de la
fonction publique on est pensionné et
donc on reste toujours au service
justement de l'intérêt général et donc
en tant qu'agent et c'est très important
pour nous en tout cas ce lien qu'il doit
qu'il devait rester entre actif et
pensionné d'ailleurs le terme de
retraité il est presque impropre pour
nommer un fonctionnaire et donc on
aurait aimé justement pouvoir réussir à
convaincre mais on n'a pas n'a pas
abouti à justement ce lien extrêmement
important entre actif et pensionné qui
dépasse évidemment je partage ce qu'a
dit mon collègue sur les risques
financiers pour les retraités mais
surtout qui dépassent la question du
financier et qui
solidifie le statut parce que par
rapport à la question que vous posiez
sur les retraites on n'a pas encore une
contractualisation suffisamment
importante pour y voir déjà des effets
majeurs peut-être tu pourras répondre
plus précisément mais on voit bien qu'on
est dans la même dans la même évolution
que la fermeture des statues des régimes
spéciaux dire que la loi de la fonction
publique elle prévoit à terme une montée
forte de la contractualisation pour ne
plus recruter au moins sur certains
ministères de fonctionnaires et donc ça
évidemment ça conduit à basculer la
fonction publique dans le régime général
et ça évidemment des conséquences
extrêmement importants comme le manque
d'emploi dans la fonction publique merci
Madame Perret monsieur crans souhaité
prendre la parole quelques éléments
complémentaires sur les critères d'appel
d'offres bon évidemment les solidarités
on a cité solidarité
intergénérationnelle mais il y a aussi
des solidarités familiales qu'on appelle
familiales c'est les droits familiaux
dans les dans la prise en charge des
ayants droits ça fait partie de l'accord
sur la santé
et
c'était important qu'on qu'il figure et
on a même réussi un petit peu à faire
intervenir des droits ce qu'on appelle
des solidarités indiciaires c'est-à-dire
que les gens qui ont des rémunérations
des indices faibles dans les fonctions
publiques cotisent un tout petit peu
moins que ceux qui ont des meilleurs
indices donc il y a une en effet un
effet solidarité entre entre catégories
d'agents publics après sur
sur les
le cabinet conseil il y a un cabinet qui
a effectivement travaillé avec la dgfp
donc la direction générale de
l'administration de la fonction publique
qui a aussi travaillé avec les
organisations syndicales pour justement
avoir un langage commun sur la
protection sociale complémentaire et
c'était pas forcément
inutile d'avoir
un logiciel un peu commun pour pour
aborder les négociations puisque comme
je vous l'ai dit tout à l'heure c'était
une négociation qu'on a eu avec avec les
employeurs publics
sur la pénibilité alors sur la retraite
les évolutions dans dans la fonction
publique il y en a très peu finalement
donc il a été évoqué tout à l'heure la
mise en place d'une retraite progressive
pour les fonctions les agents publics
qui n'existaient pas jusqu'à présent
c'est quelque chose qui peut être pris
avec intérêt quand même pour les pour
les agents quand on sait que
effectivement avec l'allongement de la
durée de cotisation et de l'âge légal
qui va se décaler peut-être je ne perds
pas
ça va créer des problèmes pour les fins
de carrière on l'a déjà ces problèmes là
dans plein de professions j'ai entendu
tout à l'heure
le l'exemple de l'enseignante qui avait
du mal à tenir jusqu'au bout après il y
a les durées requises dans les
catégories actives qui n'ont pas été
modifiées mais n'empêche qu'il faudra
quand même deux ans de plus pour ces
personnes-là pour pouvoir ouvrir leurs
droits
il y a une question de portabilité des
droits à l'intérieur des catégories
actives qui a été mise aussi en place
c'est-à-dire que sur les par exemple
douaniers ou policiers et qu'on a un
certain nombre d'années en catégorie
active et qu'on devient surveillant
pénitentiaire on pourra garder les
droits acquis dans l'une pour aller dans
l'autre ce qui était pas le cas jusqu'à
présent enfin voilà il y a des petites
choses comme ça
il y aura plus besoin de la clause
d'achèvement donc finir sa carrière dans
la catégorie active pour en bénéficier
enfin des petites choses qui ont qui
vont être un petit peu
enfin qui vont améliorer un petit peu le
sort des agents publics mais qui quand
même enfin la toile de fond c'est quand
même plus deux ans pour tout le monde ça
c'est quand même quelque chose
enfin d'incroyable parce que finalement
vous êtes dans une catégorie active on
vous permettait de partir avant parce
que vous étiez censé être
usé par votre métier en difficulté en
fait on considère que vous pouvez quand
même faire deux ans de plus donc c'est
quand même pas exceptionnel après sur la
protection sociale juste un dernier mot
couplage santé prévoyance ça c'est
quelque chose qu'on réclame depuis le
début donc avoir les deux les deux les
deux couvertures proposées en même temps
quoi ça c'est une garantie qui serait
très intéressante d'obtenir
merci pour ces réponses la parole est à
Monsieur Stéphane Lenormand pour le
groupe
merci Madame Présidente je remercie à
mon tour les trois interlocuteurs qui
ont exposé un peu leur point de vue je
m'attarderai pas trop sur la réforme des
retraites parce que je partage assez vos
inquiétudes par rapport à la fonction
publique donc sans être comme on dit en
discrétion je j'aimerais avoir un peu
votre retour d'expérience parce que vous
en avez un qui est bien plus affûté que
le mien mais j'ai vraiment l'impression
qu'il y a un malaise dans les
différentes fonctions publiques il y a
il y a des problématiques qui se posent
il y a une usure et c'est vrai que deux
ans de plus pour beaucoup ça apparaît
comme quelque chose vraiment qu'il est
les enfants se complètement et une des
remarques qui m'est venue au travers de
mes différentes
visites et contacts c'est le problème un
peu qu'il y a en termes de mobilité à
l'intérieur
des trois fonctions publiques que vous
avez cité et je pense que ça peut avoir
un impact important sur la dimension
santé bien-être au travail et aussi une
effrayure supplémentaire par rapport à
cette réformes et j'aimerais avoir un
peu votre retour sur ce point-là et le
deuxième élément je crois que c'est
madame qui a évoqué un départ autour de
64 ans j'aimerais savoir si c'est une
moyenne sur les 3 versants des fonctions
publiques ou si c'est une une seule des
fonctions publiques qui étaient
concernée voilà merci merci
merci monsieur le député par rapport à
votre à votre question sur la mobilité
notamment à l'usure dans les dans les
trois fonctions publiques avec deux ans
de deux ans de plus effectivement une
année de plus on le sait c'est en termes
de sinistralité en tous les cas par
rapport à la santé c'est 10 points de
plus en termes de sinistralité donc
c'est énorme
quand j'évoquais tout à l'heure dans mes
propos une réforme de la PSC mais qui en
réalité était trois réformes puisque il
y a les négociations interministérielles
et je suis tout à fait d'accord avec le
collègue en disant que c'est
indispensable pour qu'il m'utilisation
des risques qui est un couplage santé et
prévoyance plein et entier pour une
protection sociale complémentaire
complète et de et de qualité
cette je reviens à cette mobilité
aujourd'hui puisque c'est en réalité
trois réformes avec trois spécificités
liées aux trois versants de la fonction
publique
donc les mobilités forcément avec en
plus ce que disait le collègue par
rapport à la portabilité c'est aussi un
vrai un véritable sujet qu'il faut
prendre en compte et qui ne facilite pas
les choses dans la matière voilà
merci alors je vais répondre à la
dernière question avant de reprendre
c'est pas tout à fait exactement le même
âge moyen de départ selon les trois
versants de la fonction publique c'est
actuellement pour l'État 63 ans et 8
mois 63 ans et 5 mois pour la
territoriale et 62 ans et 10 mois pour
l'hospitalière mais ça s'explique
évidemment par la Constitution un des
différentes fonctions publiques et ça
renvoie justement aux questions que vous
posiez auparavant sur la question de
l'usure de la pénibilité de des agents
qui ont de plus en plus de mal à aller
au bout de leur carrière ça se traduit
évidemment très clairement dans un
certain nombre de secteurs et j'ai pas
besoin de développer beaucoup la
question de la fonction publique
hospitalière parce que elle nous saute
aux yeux évidemment tant on recherche
des soignants partout sur le territoire
mais quand même deux éléments
intéressants à connaître l'âge moyen
d'inaptitude pour une aide-soignante
c'est 48 ans l'âge moyen d'inaptitude
pour une infirmière c'est 52 ans
ça quelle que soit d'ailleurs son statut
c'est important aussi de le dire parce
que bien évidemment il faut travailler à
améliorer cette question de pouvoir
d'une part permettre d'être des tes
parents anticipé mais aussi pouvoir
créer des conditions à une mobilité pour
des postes avec moins d'exposition mais
c'est vrai aussi pour les
aides-soignantes ou les infirmières qui
sont du secteur privé et qui elles n'ont
pas du tout de cadre leur permettant de
partir avant c'est pourquoi nous à la
CGT on demande de travailler sur une
harmonisation de droits et des parents
anticipé par rapport au métier sans
prendre en compte uniquement le statut
et puis il y a évidemment d'autres
possibilités il en existait un que nous
en tout cas nous défendons et dont nous
souhaitons de retour il s'appelait la
cessation progressive d'activité dans la
fonction publique et il donnait
d'extrêmement bons résultats il
permettait de partir trois ans avant
l'âge légal avec la possibilité y
compris d'harmoniser son temps de
travail et son temps de rémunération sur
les trois années par rapport à la fois à
aux intérêts du service et aux intérêts
aussi individuels de l'agent ça
fonctionnait très bien ça permettait par
exemple dans l'éducation nationale de
faire partir des gens dans de bonnes
conditions avant que il soit usé ça
permettait aussi beaucoup d'éviter que
l'employeur public agisse comme
l'employeur privé mon collègue le disait
c'est-à-dire et tendance à se
débarrasser des agents qui sont
considérés comme n'étant plus productif
ou inapte à l'exercice des missions de
service public et les mettre en
inaptitude et les licencis simplement on
les envoyant au chômage cette fois-ci
encore plus longtemps avant l'âge légal
à la retraite si on décale à 64 ans
l'âge d'accès au droit
merci Madame Perret monsieur
cransoullier ajouter quelque chose
rapidement je suis désolé je vais mettre
du temps
sur le malaise donc parlienne sur le
député alors en fait il est pas neuf le
malaise il est il est assez ancien en
fait il est un peu correlé aussi à
disons plus de 10 ans de gel de la
valeur du point d'indice
chez les fonctionnaires et les agents
publics ça a un lien quand même assez
direct et puis il est aussi lié à la
période covid qu'on a passé les agents
publics notamment je parle des agents de
du secteur de la santé mais pas
uniquement mais ont été en première
ligne il y a eu le Ségur bien sûr mais
ça n'a pas ça ne résout pas toute la
question mais franchement aujourd'hui
effectivement les agents publics ont un
peu l'impression de manquer de
reconnaissance
globalement et d'ailleurs on le voit
très très nettement dans les concours
qui sont organisés pour l'attractivité
des métiers aujourd'hui dans les
fonctions publiques vous avez de moins
en moins et ces documenter aussi dans le
rapport annuel de la fonction publique
sur la baisse drastique du nombre
d'inscrits au concours de recrutement un
signe quand même qui est incroyable il
faut il faut vraiment faire attention à
ça parce que vous allez avoir des ports
entiers de la fonction publique qui vont
plus trouver de recrutement alors
c'est un vrai sujet et c'est pour ça
qu'on a une négociation qui va s'ouvrir
avec le ministre sur les parcours
professionnels et les rémunérations et
les carrières il me semble qu'il y a
c'est le moment parce que il y a des
besoins
importants à satisfaire en termes de
certes de rémunération mais aussi vous
avez parlé de mobilité il y a la
mobilité professionnelle aussi à
l'intérieur des fonctions publiques qui
n'est pas suffisamment développée on
peut encore faire des des progrès
incroyables là-dedans aussi les
mobilités entre versants aussi c'est
très peu développé donc on est vraiment
sur ces questions d'attractivité de la
fonction publique de la reconnaissance
et de la valorisation des agents dans
leur dans leur métier sans quoi on va
appauvrir et on va dégrader en fait la
qualité des services publics dans ce
pays
je vous remercie pour le groupe
rassemblement national la parole est à
Monsieur Frédéric carolier merci madame
le Président
donc effectivement vous avez parlé dans
en préambule en vérité vous vous
décrivez l'inanité de cette réforme
puisque c'est bien de parler de
l'attractivité de la fonction publique
j'ai noté que 40% des agents
s'interrogent sur leur avenir dans la
fonction publique 30% des agents
considèrent que leur métier a une
influence négative sur leur santé et
de façon générale sur la protection
sociale vous avez parlé de la corne
national interprofessionnelle la ni
notamment la complémentaire santé et la
prévoyance alors la complémentaire santé
la Nice s'applique obligatoirement pour
le privé et ses facultatif donc dans la
fonction publique
moi je connais des collectivités qui ont
négocié des accords de complémentaires
santé prise en charge de 50% comme dans
le privé et d'autres qui ne l'ont pas
fait par contre ce que j'ai pu remarquer
dans des collectivités notamment dans
des communes c'est pas obligatoire la ni
pour les collectivités
publiques n'est pas au pays dans la
fonction publique qu'elle soit
territoriale c'est pas obligatoire on
est bien d'accord dans les communes ce
que j'ai pu remarquer c'est que la
complémentaire santé les garanties sont
bien inférieures à ce qu'on peut voir
dans le privé
donc ça c'est quand même un problème
parce qu'avant de parler de retraite et
je terminerai par parler de la retraite
il est important qu'on se soigne bien
quand on est actif ça fait partie de
déroulement d'une carrière et en termes
de prévoyance c'est pareil dans la
fonction publique quelle qu'elle soit
c'est bien inférieure à ce qu'on peut
voir dans le dans le privé et en plus ce
n'est pas obligatoire alors que dans le
privé c'est obligatoire la prise en
charge à hauteur de 50%. donc ma
première question est-ce que la la
principale priorité c'est pas d'abord là
de mettre la fonction publique
territoriale ou hospitalière quelle
qu'elle soit au niveau de ce qui se fait
dans le privé au travers de la nid vous
avez parlé donc de des retraites
vous dites à juste titre que il y a
d'abord un problème sur la santé en
embauchant 300 000 fonctionnaires dans
la fonction publique hospitalière on
résoudrait quelque part la problématique
de la santé et de nos retraites mais là
c'est pareil est-ce que on peut pas
mettre le privé au niveau du public
puisqu'il y a quand même des avantages
qui existent dans le public et qu'il
faut garder comme la pension de
réversion qui n'est pas plafonné dans le
public et qu'il l'est dans le privé ou
comme la parentalité quand on a un
enfant quand on a eu trois enfants on a
10% de plus sur la pension c'est pas
plafonné dans le public et là il aurait
fallu faire la même chose dans le privé
donc par rapport à tout ça qu'est-ce que
vous pouvez nous dire
alors pour des réponses en deux minutes
s'il vous plaît quelques éléments de
réponse
dans ce que vous exposez il y a les
éléments qui procèdent de ce qu'on
appelle la labellisation ou le
référencement pour la fonction publique
d'État ou la labilisation pour la
fonction publique territoriale c'est ce
qui est en cours en ce moment et les
accords auxquels vous faites référence
ce sont des accords qui sont faits
communs par commune collectivités par
collectivité ou non comme vous le
précisiez mais c'est ce qui a cours
aujourd'hui et c'est avec de grandes
différences possibles entre
collectivités mais aussi entre le privé
et les collectivités
de même le référencement la fonction
publique d'État c'est quelque chose qui
a été négocié ministère parmiaire et ce
qui explique peut-être aussi aujourd'hui
que la mise en place de la PSC
protection sociale complémentaire avec
une négociation générale avec un même
panier de soins sur la santé pour
l'ensemble des trois versants de la
fonction de la fonction publique au
niveau
ministériel mais après des négociations
possibles ministères parmi-systères
notamment j'évoquais dans mes propos la
prévoyance qui aujourd'hui n'a pas de
pardon la prévention qui aujourd'hui
n'est il y a pas de ligne particulière
dédiée ni l'accompagnement social ou si
ce n'est que 0,5 % là où aujourd'hui on
est plutôt entre deux et trois pour cent
de la cotisation dédiée à
l'accompagnement social le volet santé a
été négocié au niveau interministériel
donc reste à négocier maintenant
ministère par ministère le volet
prévoyance dans ce qu'on expliquait lui
il est pas encore négocié du tout et
c'est pour ça qu'on appelait notamment
avec mon collègue monsieur Crance a un
couplage un couplage santé et prévoyance
pour l'ensemble
des trois versants de la fonction
publique avec une adaptation aux
spécificités de chacune d'elles
merci pour votre réponse la parole est à
Monsieur Gérard le seul pour le groupe
socialiste
merci madame la Présidente merci de vos
interventions madame messieurs je
partage complètement vos craintes sur
l'attractivité de la fonction publique
hier et aujourd'hui et la vie
d'inquiétude aussi sur le maintien de
fonction publique dynamique
quand on constate la volonté de recours
accrue au contractuel alors j'ai une
question à peu précise et j'espère que
vous ne m'en voudrez pas mais dans les
années 90 l'État a proposé à des
étudiants de s'engager dans l'éducation
nationale au terme de leurs années
d'études en contrepartie d'une
allocation l'article 14 de la loi de
juillet 91 évoquée très précisément
qu'un décret devrait venir préciser
cette prise en compte de cette
allocation pour la constitution et la
liquidation du droit à pension de
retraite se réserve de la titularisation
bien sûr dans un corps d'enseignement et
dans des conditions non fixées par
décret or le décret à ce jour n'a jamais
été publié et donc on arrive finalement
depuis 91 à une situation où les
personnels enseignants anciens
allocataires vont arriver en retraite et
s'inquiète à juste titre ou à double
titre à la fois de la non prise en
compte de leur année d'un locataire et
bien sûr de la réforme qui est proposée
alors nous devons nous sommes parlons-en
nous devons absolument restaurer la
confiance en la loi et en la parole de
l'État donc nous allons bien sûr
interpeller la puissance publique sur
ces questions là mais avez-vous
connaissance d'autres difficultés
sectorielles qui grignotent ainsi des
droits à la retraite dans les autres
fonctions publiques ou peut-être même
dans la fonction publique de l'éducation
nationale enfin vous avez évoqué à juste
raison à juste titre l'association
progressive d'activité et quelle mesure
concrètes proposez-vous pour
réinstaurer une cessation d'activité
digne de ce nom dans des fonctions
publiques je vous remercie
merci beaucoup
pardon sur la cessation progressive
d'activité nous on est très simple il y
avait un système qui fonctionnait très
bien donc on demande le rétablissement
de ce système et comme on est un peu
gourmand on demande même de l'étudier
pour l'élargir au delà de la fonction
publique parce que on sait bien et
d'ailleurs le ministre du Travail la
reconnu lui-même voilà quelques minutes
quand il était ici le système de de
départ anticipé dans le privé ne
fonctionne pas du tout et donc
inspirons-nous de ce qui fonctionne ce
qui fonctionnait très bien c'était la
CPA fonction publique ancienne méthode
et donc nous demandons sont
rétablissement sur la question
évidemment des allocataires nous sommes
évidemment favorables à ce que vous
rouvriez le dossier nous sommes nous
d'ailleurs très intéressé par la
question justement du pré recrutement
parce que ce système y compris la
question de l'attractivité des agents de
la fonction publique ça pourrait aussi
se travailler y compris la mixité
sociale d'accès
à la fonction publique je rappelle que
quand même à la création des trois
versions de la fonction publique la
territoriale notamment avait ce rôle
justement de d'ascension d'ascenseur
social pardon et et permettait justement
d'intégrer le maximum de citoyens pour
leur donner une perspective de carrière
sur le long terme et les faire évoluer
au cours de leur carrière publique et
donc nous sommes très favorables à
regarder évidemment aussi comment on
pourrait valoriser aussi le retour à des
prêts recrutement qui contraient
complètement dans la la carrière et la
retraite à la fois le déroulement de
carrière anxiété salaire et retraite
parce que bien évidemment la retraite
dépend aussi beaucoup de la rémunération
et de l'évolution de la rémunération
qu'on a pu avoir cette rupture
d'ailleurs entre actif et retraités
c'est aussi un moyen de rompre aussi la
progressivité des rémunérations de la
carrière ce qui fait quand même la
marque
d'un fonctionnaire
et puis il faut regarder effectivement
mais vous avez été attentif lors des
débats sur la question justement de
salariés qui avait eu des tucs ou des
contrats et des qui avaient échappé
justement complètement à cette à cette
comptabilisation justement pour leur
retraite nous avions été alertés nous
d'ailleurs l'an dernier par ces salariés
qui commencent à arriver massivement
justement à la retraite aujourd'hui et
nous étions intervenus au niveau de la
CNAV la CNAV nous y ont répondu c'est
intéressant la petite anecdote ça sera
une monnaie d'échange au moment de la
réforme des retraites bon vous voyez que
ça n'a été une mais tant mieux pour tous
ces 300 ou 350 000 salariés qui sont
concernés il y en a parmi eux il y a
beaucoup aussi de de d'emplois aidés qui
ont ensuite été intégrés dans la
fonction publique notamment territoriale
et donc il faut regarder si tout est
compté parce que là il y a certainement
encore un certain nombre de contrats qui
n'ont pas forcément donner
lieu à cotisations et donc à validation
pour les années de retraite mais on peut
vous faire une petite liste
merci Madame Perret monsieur cross très
rapidement
donc c'est un dispositif qui existait
dans le temps ça s'appelait la cparation
progressive d'activité qui a été
supprimée pour diverses raisons il est
rétabli mais de manière un peu dégradée
à travers un projet qui prévoit une
retraite la mise en place de retraite
progressive dans les fonctions publiques
donc ces deux ans voilà je légale
d'ouverture des droits c'est pas du tout
dans les mêmes conditions de la CPA et
après on en a pas encore les détails
l'éligibilité des agents et ainsi de
suite mais tout ça en fait c'est un
dispositif qui tend à se rapprocher un
peu de ce qui se fait dans le secteur
privé mais qui qui est loin de ce qui
existait précédemment et puis après sur
les sur les
sur les recrutements je pense que pour
nous à la CFDT il faut il faut
diversifier les voies d'accès il y a des
la voix du concours il y a trois types
de concours différents il y a d'autres
formes d'accès à la fonction publique et
je pense que c'est par là qu'on arrivera
effectivement à rendre les métiers plus
accessibles plus attractif notamment et
bon il y a une partie aussi autour de
l'apprentissage qui qui peut se faire
pour les fonctions publiques
donc il faut réfléchir à tout ça dans la
dans le dans l'avenir qui proche puisque
on aura ce temps de négociations ou de
concertation avec le ministre sur les
carrières les recrutements donc dans
dans l'année 2023
merci et pour le groupe GDR
notre dernière intervenant nom des
moindres la parole est à monsieur le
Président Chassaigne merci madame la
Présidente je voulais revenir sur deux
points très rapidement d'une part sur la
prise en compte de l'invalidité qui
renvoyait à la négociation sur la
protection sociale complémentaire qui
doit s'achever fin mars 2023 c'est du
moins ce qui a été prévu aujourd'hui la
mise à la retraite est d'office pour les
fonctionnaires ce qui bien évidemment
pénalise Jean-Jean concerné leur famille
dans le privé il y a un trimestre
d'invalidité qui donne droit à un
trimestre cotisé et ce qu'il y aura des
améliorations par rapport à ça la
deuxième question que je vais poser
c'est sur les conséquences de l'appel
aux mutuelles et aux organismes privés
aux assurances privées notamment qui va
être ce qui va s'accentuer avec la
suppression des régimes spéciaux parce
que d'une part il y a ceux qui ont été
recrutés au statut
une certaine prise en compte d'autres
qui sont sur nos nouveaux entrants des
nouveaux entrants qui vraisemblablement
vont davantage faire appel donc soit
mutuelle s'assurance privée il y aura
une marchandisation quels effets ça peut
avoir sur les mutuelles en fonction
publique actuelle par exemple et quel
risque de ne pas remporter les appels
d'offres au profit de qui quand on ira
vers le moins 10 ans vers moins de
solidarité et enfin pour essayer de de
mieux être protégé quel périmètre des
appels d'offres quelle serait selon vous
les niveaux de segmentation qui seraient
nécessaires pour mieux répondre pour
avoir plus de solidarité à la sortie
donc ça ferait un écart extrêmement
important et puis en plus ce périmètre
d'actifs échappant alors pour six années
j'ai bien compris que c'était
itératif la protection sociale
complémentaire c'est tous les 6 ans bien
de se retrouver d'un seul coup et de
façon très très brutale avec des
périmètres qui peuvent être divisés par
deux moi j'ai bien en tête l'exemple de
de d'une mutuelle de l'éducation
nationale qui est la MGEN se retrouver
avec la moitié des des puisque à peu
près autant d'actifs de retraités que
d'actifs te retrouver avec la moitié des
des adhérents et de se retrouver ainsi
avec un plan social automatiquement à
conduire et puis s'adapter les six
années au bout de 6 ans si il y avait de
veau un nouveau lotissement avec un
nouvel appel d'offres en la matière donc
effectivement les conséquences peuvent
être carrément dramatiques et pour les
cotisants que sont les retraités et pour
les mutuelles elles elles-mêmes quant à
leur survie et
au bilan social qui pourrait être
largement affecté par rapport aux
salariés
merci beaucoup est-ce qu'il y a un
dernier mot
très très rapide vous dire que nous on a
évidemment
à coeur de défendre la spécificité de
des agents de la fonction publique mais
on se dit que ce sont aussi tous des
travailleurs des travailleurs et qui a
nécessité d'harmoniser un certain nombre
de droits privés et public c'est vrai
par exemple pour les questions
d'invalidité mais c'est aussi vrai en
amont sur les questions de reclassement
parce que pour ne pas arriver jusqu'à
l'invalidité il faut permettre justement
aux salariés ou aux agents quand ils
sont de la fonction publique de pouvoir
évoluer dans leur métier être reclassé
avant d'être en situation d'invalidité
de façon à ne pas être mis dehors
justement que ce soit d'une entreprise
ou d'une grande administration de la
fonction publique et ça ce travail là il
est pas suffisamment mis en amont c'est
ce qui explique d'ailleurs que nous
avions tous dit au ministre qu'il ne
fallait pas commencer par une la
question des retraites mais bien
commencer par la question du travail et
de son évolution son contenu et de ce
que ça veut dire en termes de carrière
que ce soit pour les salariés du privé
ou les salariés de la fonction publique
il nous a pas écouté malheureusement et
nous en sommes dans nous sommes là dans
une impasse
merci j'ai une dernière demande
d'intervention monsieur Gabriel Amar
pour le groupe
Gabriel Amar
[Musique]
à vous entendre
comment dire
je
comprends et j'aime ça me révolte
de voir que finalement pour la
protection sociale pour les
complémentaires on se retrouve à avec
une culture du marché public ou de la
concession finalement
il manquerait plus pour terminer le
massacre
du mutualisme
qu'on vienne nous dire qui pourrait y
avoir une annexe qui demain obligerait
l'opérateur qui emporterait un marché de
reprendre les salariés auxquels
vous faisiez référence dans votre propos
introductif pour terminer le tableau et
cela démontre à quel point cette mise en
dans le champ concurrentiel est
totalement antinomique avec
la foi l'histoire la culture de ce que
rituel en France on
construit autour de
l'idée de la solidarité sur laquelle
vous êtes revenus tout à l'heure est-ce
que vous pourriez en quelques instants
nous rappeler les revendications de des
organisations que vous représentez
au lieu et place de cette mise en
concurrence que nous avons pour
l'instant l'état du rapport de force
et bien à subir
alors
alors merci monsieur le député pour
votre intervention et remarque et qui
m'amène à dire qu'effectivement
c'est quelque chose qu'on a essayé de
faire peser en lien avec toutes les
organisations syndicales qui sont en
termes de d'interlocuteur avec les les
pouvoirs publics
sur justement de faire prendre en compte
au maximum cette valeur et les valeurs
de solidarité les valeurs d'entraide et
pour une protection la plus globale et
large possible aujourd'hui force est de
constater dans tout ce qu'on a pu dire
qu'on n'y est pas on y est on y est pas
donc en cela si on peut se réjouir sur
la participation de l'État à la
protection sociale complémentaire de ces
agents on peut que déplorer de pas être
de paillettes et d'avoir ce risque et de
découplage par rapport à la santé et la
prévoyance le la scission qui peut y
avoir entre les actifs et les retraités
en termes de de concrètement par rapport
à leur engagement en tant que
fonctionnaire pendant la durée
d'activité et la non prise en compte de
du même agent quand il devient pensionné
et tout ça c'est quelque chose qu'on
voulait faire qu'on a voulu faire
prévaloir mais aujourd'hui et donc vos
propos me touche et sont très rassurants
dans ce que vous dans ce que vous dites
malheureusement je sais pas de quelle
manière ça pourrait être pris en compte
et c'est pour ça aussi qu'on est qu'on
est là aujourd'hui pour voir ne pas
détruire ce que vous avez dit qui a été
construit je faisais état dans mes
propos liminaires de de 75 ans de
construction de prise en compte de des
besoins spécifiques des agents
le ce qui serait le plus grand échec ce
serait d'arriver à une régression de la
couverture et de la protection sociale
par rapport à ce qui existe aujourd'hui
tout en voulant au départ bien faire
merci
un complément non
elle date pas non plus d'aujourd'hui
parce que depuis la fin de la rareté
Chazelle
les référencesments c'était déjà
répondre à des impératifs imposés par la
réglementation européenne sur la libre
concurrence non foncée et ça a fait
rentrer dans le jeu des acteurs qui n'y
étaient pas auparavant et là on passe un
une étape supplémentaire probablement
avec effectivement la possibilité pour
des opérateurs qui sont pas
traditionnellement ou historiquement
présents de venir s'implanter c'est pour
ça que dans les négociations qu'on a
mené notamment sur l'état pour la partie
santé on a essayé de border justement
autour des valeurs des grands principes
qui font de le mutualisme aujourd'hui
notamment celui de solidarité mais pas
que et d'essayer
venir dans l'accord qui a été signé par
toutes les organisations syndicales ça a
été souligné le maximum de garanties
pour essayer de se prémunir mais mais on
n'est pas effectivement à l'abri de
comportement qui pourraient dévoyé
l'esprit dans lequel ça a été fait alors
sur la prévoyance j'en parle pas parce
que effectivement on est très très loin
de la l'aboutissement du du dossier
et l'invalidité dont vous parliez
monsieur chassen c'est aussi un angle
mort le gouvernement veut enfin veut pas
en parler avec nous pour l'instant on
nous dit c'est pas dans les retraites
c'est dans la protection sociale
complémentaire quand on veut en parler
d'un protection sociale complémentaire
ni dit bah oui mais c'est très compliqué
on va pas y arriver d'un seul coup il va
falloir s'y reprendre à plusieurs fois
enfin voilà donc on est assez inquiet
là-dessus quand même
si je peux rajouter juste un mot parce
que ça nous renvoie quand même en
retraite une des leçons à tirer de ce
projet de loi c'est aussi qu'il fait la
part belle l'ouverture aux assurances
complémentaires
issues du privé donc on est bien sur le
même sujet et que aujourd'hui les
principaux
fossoyeurs justement du mutualisme ce
sont les assurances privées j'attire
votre attention aussi sur le danger que
rencontre aujourd'hui les groupes de
protection sociale spécifiques
issus des branches qui traitent
justement et qui donne des réponses à
des salariés avec leur spécificité
professionnelle qui sont
particulièrement dans le collimateur et
mutuelle comme GPS sont vraiment
extrêmement fragilisés en ce moment et
notamment un certain nombre de risques
notamment par exemple avec les
transferts des cotisations à l'URSSAF
qui peuvent revenir dans le débat au
Sénat
illustrerait un des premiers dangers qui
marqueraient un coût important contre
ces CGPS
j'attire aussi votre attention sur le
danger que les risques en matière
d'action sociale justement que que les
employeurs veulent voir disparaître de
nos retraites complémentaires
merci à tous les trois de ces échanges
et de votre participation à nos travaux
je vais suspendre trois minutes pour la
seconde partie du débat le temps
d'accueillir monsieur le ministre
la séance est reprise la parole est à
Monsieur Stanislas Guérini ministre de
la transformation et de la fonction
publique
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés je voudrais
peut-être commencer par remercier le
groupe GDR d'avoir rendu possible ce
moment de débat et d'échange sur une
thématique qui vous en doutez en tant
que mise de la transformation et la
fonction publique mes chers mais de vous
remercier d'avoir lié le sujet retraite
et celui de la protection sociale des
agents de la fonction publique je pense
que
lier ces deux sujets c'est être dans
l'esprit de la loi de 1946 et c'est dans
cet esprit là que je m'inscris et que
j'inscris l'action du gouvernement donc
si vous me permettez je leur a propos
liminaire pas forcément trop long mais
pour nous permettre d'avoir des échanges
en reprenant dans l'ordre que vous avez
suggéré au fond par ce débat d'abord par
un point d'entrée retraite dans notre
discussion et ensuite élargir au sujet
de la protection sociale complémentaire
la protection des agents de la fonction
publique et puis peut-être au-delà du
parcours de carrière de rémunération
d'attractivité la fonction publique
parce que je pense que ces questions de
retraite et de travail et de conduite de
parcours au sein de la fonction publique
sont en réalité intimement les peut-être
quelques points pour commencer pour
cadrer le sujet retraite et les mesures
spécifiques que le gouvernement apporté
à travers le projet de loi pour la
fonction publique autour de trois
principes le premier c'est un principe
d'évolution symétrique des paramètres
entre les salariés du privé et les
agences de la fonction publique sur les
mesures d'efforts qui sont demandées à
tous les salariés du privé qui soient
les salariés du pays pardon qui soit des
salariés privés ou des agents de la
fonction publique et donc c'est la
raison pour laquelle à la fois sur le
décalage de l'arche d'ouverture des
droits mais aussi sur l'accélération de
la durée de cotisation les agents du
public seront concernés au même titre
que les salariés du privé que ce soit
des agents de catégories actives ou des
agents sédentaires
deuxième élément avoir en tête au moment
d'entrer dans ces débats spécifiques à
la fonction publique dans le sujet
retraite c'est que le choix que le
gouvernement a fait à la différence de
la réforme de 2019 c'est de ne pas
proposer de convergence systémique des
deux systèmes de retraite celui du privé
d'un côté et celui de la fonction
publique de l'autre le choix qui a été
fait c'est sur les principes qui
conditionnent le versement des pensions
pour les agents de la fonction publique
c'est de conserver les caractéristiques
fondamentales du système de retraite
pour les agents de la fonction publique
à la fois sur le calcul qui est fondé
sur les six derniers mois
comparativement au privé qui est sur les
25 meilleures années mais aussi sur
l'assiette de cotisations pour les
agents de la fonction publique qui
reposent sur la rémunération
indiciaire et non pas indemnitaire donc
c'est l'autre différence fondamentale et
puis sur le fait de conserver le
principe des catégories actives sont 700
000 agents dans les trois versants de la
fonction publique qui sont aujourd'hui
dites catégories actives c'est-à-dire au
fond la prise en compte de la pénibilité
pour la fonction publique donc sur tous
ces éléments-là ont conserve les
caractéristiques fondamentales des
retraites dans la fonction publique je
me permets d'ailleurs d'indiquer je le
fais systématiquement que il y a un
effort du budget de l'État pour financer
le système de retraite de la fonction
publique il est important c'est chaque
année en 2023 ou en 2000 de pardon oui
en 2022 c'est 64,4 milliards d'euros qui
sont consacrés au versement des pensions
pour le périmètre de l'État mais
j'entends parfois dans le débat public à
tort à mon sens des éléments induits
disant au fond il y a un effort de
l'État pour financer un effort du budget
de l'État pour financer notre système de
retraite mais
la version induite ce serait qu'on
financerait au fond un système de
privilégié où les agents de la fonction
publique seraient privilégié par rapport
aux salariés du privé moi c'est une idée
sur lequel je m'élève systématiquement
en faux ce qui convient de comparer
c'est le taux de remplacement pour les
salariés du privé et pour les agents de
la fonction publique c'est-à-dire ce
qu'on a au fond au moment de sa retraite
par rapport à ce qu'on avait pendant sa
carrière professionnelle et ce taux de
remplacement il est à 0,6% près
identique entre le privé et les agents
de la fonction publique autour de 74%.
donc il y a un effort du budget de
l'État mais qui est beaucoup plus lié à
des déséquilibres démographiques qui
sont le fondement même au fond de la
réforme dans son ensemble qui sont très
accentués pour la fonction publique
d'État il faut avoir en tête que il y a
aujourd'hui au moment où on se parle
0,86 fonctionnaire actif pour un
fonctionnaire retraité ce qui montre
bien les enjeux y compris de dés
démographique et donc de financement qui
explique l'effort budgétaire qui est
fait par l'État pour financer le régime
des retraites de la fonction publique
donc ça c'est le deuxième élément sur
lequel je voulais insister convergence
où on va dire évolution symétrique des
paramètres mais en revanche préservation
des caractéristiques fondamentales qui
constituent le système de retraite de la
fonction publique et puis le troisième
élément c'est un certain nombre de
progrès que va permettre cette réforme
au-delà des mesures d'efforts que je
présente de façon tout à fait
transparente symétrique entre le privé
et le public bien dans la réforme qui
vous est présentée et proposé par le
gouvernement il y a un certain nombre
d'avancées qui vont nous permettre
d'améliorer le système je voudrais en
citer 5 qui me semble importante et je
vais le faire de façon rapide on aura
peut-être l'occasion de creuser ces
éléments là en faisant remarquer en
préambule que toutes les mesures
spécifiques fonction publique dans le
texte retraite en réalité
les sujets d'adaptation et d'aménagement
des carrières et je crois que c'est au
fond le cœur du débat que nous devrions
avoir sur le sujet des retraites la
première c'est l'instauration pour le
public du dispositif de retraite
progressive qui n'était pas existant
pour la fonction publique il y avait
avant 2010 la cessation progressive
d'activité mais nous venons introduire
un dispositif de retraite progressive je
le dis de façon très simple ça permet à
partir d'une de 62 ans âge d'ouverture
des droits moins 2 ans d'aménager son
temps de travail c'est-à-dire de se
mettre à temps partiel et de préserver
sa rémunération parce qu'on va par
anticipation toucher une partie de sa
pension de retraite pour maintenir sa
rémunération en globale et donc c'est
une un nouveau dispositif qui serait
introduit pour la fonction publique et
qui permet d'offrir là un outil
d'aménagement des carrières qui est tout
à fait intéressant et qu'il faudra
mettre en activité je crois là c'est la
vraie question et le vrai enjeu je pense
notamment aux professeur je pense
notamment à l'éducation nationale dans
lequel se dispositif pour être tout à
fait pertinent et ça fait l'objet des
discussions que j'ai avec les
organisations syndicales je profite du
de la mention des professeurs et
l'éducation nationale pour mentionner le
fait que a été porté un amendement par
différents groupes parlementaires à
l'occasion du débat à l'Assemblée
nationale sur le fait de permettre aux
professeurs du primaire de partir à la
date anniversaire de leur retraite je
veux indiquer ici que c'est un
amendement sur lequel le gouvernement
était favorable et que nous souhaitons
reprendre à l'occasion du débat au Sénat
je crois que ça serait une mesure de
justice pour les professeurs du primaire
par rapport au professeur du secondaire
je ferme là cette incise donc premier
dispositif la retraite progressive
deuxième amélioration qui est permise
par la réforme des retraites c'est le
fait de rendre totalement portable les
droits qui sont associés aux 700 000
agents de catégorie active ou super
active dans la fonction publique le
système préalable c'est que vous n'aviez
aucun intérêt quand vous étiez par
exemple policier à devenir douanier ou
quand vous étiez dans l'administration
pénitentiaire à rejoindre la police
parce que vous perdiez tout le bénéfice
à qui des années de service que vous
aviez passé en tant que policier ou
surveillant pénitentiaire par exemple
donc nous portons dans le projet de loi
une portabilité complète des droits à la
fois sur les durées de service mais
aussi sur les différentes bonifications
associées aux catégories actives je
crois que c'est une vraie avancée là
aussi pour permettre des mobilités de
carrière et je le dis en parlant des
catégories actives en précisant que nous
laissons inchangés la durée de service
c'est-à-dire ce que nous bougeons pour
les catégories actifs c'est l'âge
d'ouverture des droits mais nous
laissons inchangés la durée de service
c'était 17 ans ou 27 ans pour avoir le
droit respectivement de partir à la
retraite à 52 ou 57 ans âge d'ouverture
de droit qui va être décalé de deux ans
donc
le deuxième dispositif spécifique on
améliore les droits des catégories
actifs troisième spécificité nous
améliorons la situation des agents
contractuels de la fonction publique qui
parfois faisait le même métier que les
catégories actives je pense à des aides
soignants par exemple mais n'avaient ni
le bénéfice du compte de prévention du
C2P du privé ni le bénéfice des années
d'anticipation droit à des départs à la
retraite liés aux catégories actives là
nous portons une mesure spécifique dans
le projet de loi de retraite pour
permettre à des agents contractuels
titularisés de pouvoir prendre en compte
toutes leurs années passées en tant que
contact actuel c'est très important il y
a plus de 100000 lettres soignants qui
sont aujourd'hui des contractuels de la
fonction publique d'État qui ont parfois
cinq ans à 6 ans de service passés en
contrat va nous permettons pour ces
aides-soignants qui seront titularisés
que ces cinq ans ou 6 ans elle compte
pas pour rien il pas pour rien mais il
soit intégré à leur durée de service
c'est là aussi une vraie mesure
d'attractivité sur le fait de pouvoir
donner un bénéfice au fait de rejoindre
la titularisé dans la fonction publique
quatrième mesure spécifique le fait de
donner la possibilité je le précise en
insistant vraiment aux agents publics
qui le souhaitent de pouvoir travailler
au-delà de la limite d'âge des 67 ans il
y avait une différence publique privée
que nous venons gommer puisque dans le
privé la limite dash et 70 ans c'est à
dire l'âge d'annulation de la décote + 3
ans dans le public il y avait quelques
menus dérogations mais pour des agents
qui le souhaitent qui faisaient la
demande alors employeur en disant je
serai intéressé de travailler une année
ou deux années de plus ça n'était pas
possible et donc on vient harmoniser la
possibilité donnée aux agents publics
j'insiste une deuxième fois qui le
souhaite évidemment et qui en font la
demande de pouvoir travailler au-delà de
la limite de 67 ans aujourd'hui et donc
en alignant la limite d'âge avec celle
du privé et puis dernière mesure que je
considère vraiment comme une avancée qui
est très importante
nous venons travailler aux questions de
prévention de l'usure et de la
pénibilité et je crois que c'est ça
aussi la révolution parfois culturelle
managériale qu'on doit introduire dans
la fonction publique c'est de pouvoir
avoir des dispositifs de réparation je
mentionnais à l'instant les catégories
actives parce que je mène un métier
pénible je viens avoir un âge
d'ouverture des droits qui est anticipé
par rapport à l'âge des sédentaires mais
beaucoup plus
développé nos dispositifs je dirais
notre investissement pour mieux prévenir
l'usure et la pénibilité et c'est ce que
nous venons faire en créant un fond
dédié pour les soignants aux métiers des
établissements hospitaliers et
médico-sociaux c'est-à-dire de la
fonction publique hospitalière mais
aussi de la fonction publique
territoriale en consacrant envir de 100
millions d'euros tous les ans c'est à
dire un demi milliard d'euros sur le
quinquennat pour développer des
dispositifs de prévention de l'usure et
de la pénibilité ça veut dire pour
pouvoir aménager des postes de travail
faire en sorte que le métier puisse être
moins pénible pour pouvoir financer des
formations pour pouvoir éventuellement
changer de métier et donc c'est cette
investissement là un de mes milliards
d'euros sur le quinquennat centré sur
les établissements hospitaliers
médico-sociaux que nous venons porter
c'est un des bénéfices que permettra de
porter cette réforme des retraites qui
est présentée par le gouvernement je
précise que nous avons en ce moment des
discussions avec les employeurs
territoriaux pour là aussi pour la
fonction publique territoriale qui est
moins couverte par les dispositifs de
catégories actives faire naître des
dispositifs des instruments collectifs
de prévention de l'usure et de la
pénibilité et c'est tout le travail que
nous sommes en train de mener avec les
employeurs territoriaux peut-être en
mentionnant ce dernier point ça fait au
fond la transition avec la thématique de
la protection des agents publics parce
que vous voyez que ce que nous devons
porter c'est notre capacité à investir
sur l'aménagement des carrières est-ce
que je suis capable d'aménager mon temps
de travail c'est la retraite progressive
est-ce que je suis capable d'aménager
mon poste de travail c'est les fonds
d'usure que nous créons est-ce que je
suis capable de changer de métier c'est
là aussi pouvoir financer éventuellement
une formation professionnelle pour
aménager éventuellement une fin de
carrière et c'est l'objet des avancées
que nous avons porté ces dernières
années sur je serai rapide sur cet
élément et je pense qu'il fera partie de
nos échanges les dispositifs de
protection sociale complémentaires je
crois que c'est très important il y
avait des différences importantes entre
le privé et le public quand au mécanisme
de protection sociale complémentaire à
la fois dans les volets santé et dans
les volets prévoyance et donc c'est par
les accords je le précise
anime entre les syndicats de la fonction
publique que nous avons pu obtenir dans
le précédent quinquennat nous avons
avancé de façon je crois très positive
pour les millions d'agents qui sont
concernés par ce type de dispositif sur
le volet de la protection sociale
complémentaire pour l'instant sur le
volet santé il est cet accord là en
cours de déclinaison ministérielle pour
la fonction publique d'État en cours de
déclinaison pour la fonction publique
territoriale et hospitalière et c'est
l'objet des discussions que nous avons
sur les dispositifs de prévoyance qui
sont très importants qui couvrent les
risques les plus lourds je pense à
l'invalidité je pense au décès je pense
à l'incapacité c'est à dire aux arrêts
maladie de longue durée qui fait l'objet
des discussions et qui fait d'ailleurs
l'objet d'un accord de méthode avec des
organisations syndicales et donc j'ai
indiqué aux organisations syndicales
dans le cadre du dialogue social que
nous avons dans l'année 2023 que je
souhaitais évidemment aboutir dans le
premier semestre avec les organisations
syndicales sur ce volet prévoyance qui
peut être plus complexe en termes de
choix structurels que nous aurons à
faire que la protection sur le volet
santé mais qui est tout aussi important
et qui vient et qui doit venir couvrir
les agents de la fonction publique de
risque lourd je mentionnais évidemment
l'incapacité d'invalidité ou les risques
autour du décès la couverture sur ces
sujets là voilà parce que peut-être j'ai
déjà été trop long je laisse peut-être
des chances que nous pourrons avoir ce
dernier sujet qui sont
techniques parfois complexes mais qui je
crois sont essentiels pour la protection
des agents de la fonction publique et
vraiment prendre par allonger au débat
je suis aussi à votre entière
disposition pour élargir nos sujets
d'échanges sur les questions de parcours
d'aménagement de carrière parce que je
veux réinsister là-dessus pour conclure
je crois que ces questions elles sont en
réalité intimement liées c'est le vrai
débat derrière le débat des retraites
travaille un peu plus longtemps mais
d'être en capacité d'aménager la
carrière et les parcours des agents de
la fonction publique et je voudrais à
nouveau vous remercier d'avoir rendu
possible ces échanges
merci pour cette introduction et ce
ministre et nous en venons donc aux
questions elles sont de deux minutes je
le rappelle les réponses de 2 minutes
également il n'y a pas le droit de
réplique pour le groupe GDR la parole
est à Monsieur Pierre d'arriville
merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Ministre
dans les mesures que vous venez
d'évoquer sur la question des retraites
évidemment il n'y a aucune générosité il
y a une nécessité d'améliorer les droits
c'est évident mais la facture est un
soutenable c'est deux ans de plus
donc dans le débat qui nous occupe sur
cette question des retraites il y a pour
nous un point de blocage là fondamental
vous le savez d'ailleurs parmi les
éléments d'amélioration que vous avez
cité il y a un élément qui n'est pas
tout à fait un élément d'amélioration
mais plutôt de fragilisation concernant
la
limite d'âge de fragilisation du du
système avec la une logique de deux
parallèles qui se rejoignent avec les
coûts qui ont été portés au système de
retraite dans le dans le privé
vous avez évoqué l'effort de l'État je
pense c'est pas un effort c'est son rôle
de l'État notamment en tant qu'employeur
d'assurer le droit à la retraite celles
et ceux qui ont travaillé pour pour lui
en tant que agent de la fonction
publique
la question
posée autour de la protection sociale
complémentaire de manière
plus générale
soulève des sujets importants celui de
la santé celui de la prévention qui sont
connectés à celui des retraites
celui de l'invalidité ou les
organisations syndicales précédemment
nous expliquer qu'en fait le sujet était
en permanence renvoyé d'un côté de
l'autre mais jamais complètement abordé
avec elle que pouvez-vous nous dire là
dessus vous devez conclure sur la
protection sociale complémentaire dans
le premier semestre avez-vous dit
quelles sont vos objectifs quels sont
vos craintes quels sont les critères
selon vous qui doivent être mises en
place pour les appels d'offres avez-vous
recours à un cabinet de conseil et
pourquoi faire dans la gestion de cette
problématique ne craignez-vous pas un
effet déstructurant affaiblissant de la
mise en place de ces de ces mesures pour
la protection sociale des agents de la
fonction publique et je constate pour et
je m'arrête là
très complet donc je vais je vais
essayer de répondre je vais essayer de
consacrer peut-être moins de temps à ce
qui est au fond et notre différent
fondamentale c'est-à-dire le recul de de
l'âge pour ne pas refaire des débats qui
ont pu être davantage mené dans
l'hémicycle sur ce qui sous-tend cette
réforme et la préservation de notre
système par répartition peut-être pour
me concentrer davantage sur les
questions qui sont spécifiques à la
fonction publique et reprendre les
éléments que vous avez évoqué 1 moi ce
que je comptais dans ce que vous dites
c'est sur la limite d'âge la
fragilisation non ça n'est pas vrai
cela correspond à des agents de la
fonction publique qui font parfois la
demande de pouvoir travailler plus
longtemps souvent avec un impératif
financier je veux pas dire le contraire
je dis pas qu'ils le font par pur
bonheur de servir à la fonction publique
ça peut arriver mais ils le font souvent
avec l'évolution des familles le fait
d'avoir eu des enfants plus tardivement
et les cas que les RH de la fonction
publique
c'est souvent des parents dont les
enfants sont en train de finir leurs
études supérieures qui disent de même
moi ça m'intéresserait de pouvoir
travailler une année ou deux années de
plus pour percevoir ma rémunération dans
le cadre de ma carrière dans la fonction
publique et ensuite de basculer à la
retraite et aujourd'hui l'employeur
public est obligé de refuser je
mentionner quelques dérogations mais
elles sont très menu et donc c'est
vraiment pour répondre en l'occurrence à
des demandes des agents voilà j'en fais
pas l'alpha et l'oméga de la réforme
évidemment mais je veux simplement assez
sur le fait que ça n'est pas une
fragilisation et ça restera évidemment
sur demande des agents sur les questions
sur le autour de des questions
d'invalidité et plus largement de
protection sociale complémentaires 1 le
dispositif de protection sociale
complémentaire sur la santé est une
avancée notable et considérable pour la
protection des agents de la fonction
publique aujourd'hui ils étaient rendus
à prendre des protections
complémentaires via des mutuelles
certains le faisaient certains
ministères ou certaines collectivités
pour prendre d'autres versants de la
fonction publique avaient développé des
systèmes de complémentaires d'autres
agents ne le faisaient pas du tout et
n'étaient pas du tout couvert et donc
cet accord-là qui vise à rendre
obligatoire la prise en charge par les
employeurs publics trois versants de 50
% des couvertures de frais de santé
c'est une avancée notable pour des
millions d'agents de la fonction
publique qui est effectivement dès cette
année c'est 15 euros par mois de prise
en charge par l'employeur public d'État
ça sera à partir de 2024 30 euros par
mois de prise en charge par l'employeur
d'État donc sur le volet santé sur un
panier de soins qui a d'ailleurs été
bien négocié et qui est en cours de
déclinaison interministérielle de
qualité et qui permet d'avoir nette
progrès par rapport à ce qui était les
paniers de soins parfois négociés et qui
était de moins bonne qualité sur le
volet santé donc là il y a je crois et
d'ailleurs l'accord a été unanime avec
les organisations syndicales une vraie
avancée et puis sur le volet prévoyant
j'en dis quelques mots et on aura
peut-être l'occasion dans dans reparler
pour moi les enjeux et les éléments
décisifs c'est de savoir ce que l'on
prend comme couverture en auto-assurance
c'est à dire l'ampleur public par le
statut qui protège ou en s'appuyant sur
des acteurs tiers mutualistes ou
assureurs dans un dispositif
complémentaire mais nous aurons
peut-être l'occasion de creuser ces
enjeux
merci monsieur le ministre mais c'est
vrai qu'il y avait plusieurs questions
dans la question il y en avait même
encore une je crois
la parole est à Monsieur Stéphane
Lenormand pour le groupe liote
merci madame le Président Monsieur
ministre rapidement malgré votre
prestation vous ne serez pas changer
d'avis sur ce que je pense de votre
réforme même si je pense qu'il faut
réformer le système des retraites mais
je voudrais donc avoir des questions
plus pointues la première vous évoquez
donc cette retraite progressive dans la
fonction publique est-ce que vous
intégrez les trois versants des
fonctions publiques donc état
hospitalier et territorial ensuite
j'aimerais que l'on évoque un peu aussi
l'outre-mer parce que il y a la fonction
publique et les fonctions publiques dans
les outre-mer j'aimerais savoir quelle
est la position du gouvernement sur les
dispositifs qui existent sur ce que l'on
peut appeler un certain nombre de
bonifications outre-mer pour le calcul
des retraites je voulais savoir si vous
voulez passer aussi à la trappe aussi
elles sont maintenues et autres sujets
qui est très important pour les autres
mères c'est la réforme de l'ittr je vais
pas revenir sur sur l'historique
simplement en 2021 il y a eu un rapport
parlementaire qui avait été fait
d'ailleurs je crois par un collègue qui
est encore présent c'est Monsieur
Dunoyer
les travaux ont commencé sur ce sujet
sous l'égide du Ministère d'outre-mer
donc je crois que là-dessus c'est un
vrai sujet en termes d'attractivité et
de retour un peu de parole tenue de
l'État qui ne l'a pas été puisque je
rappellerai qu'en 2008 il devait y avoir
une mise en place d'une réflexion pour
un système de substitution à la 17
disparition de l'ittr qui n'a pas été
tenu et il va y avoir un processus entre
guillemets de compensation pour les
économies circulaires des territoires
qui n'a pas non plus été tenu donc je
crois que je voulais insister sur ce
point pour les outre-mer qui étaient
concernées par les l'ittr mais il y a
aussi une réflexion à avoir sur les
autres territoires parce que vous n'êtes
pas sans savoir qu'il y a une charte de
la vie plus importante dans les autres
mers et qui pose justement cette
attractivité et se devenir des fonctions
publiques sur les outre-mer et à ce
sujet je voudrais rappeler la position
du groupe qui est naturellement que ce
travail puisse se réaliser dans un temps
assez court qu'il bienvenue que l'État
suspend de la dégressivité du processus
qui est en cours en attendant ses
travaux et que la réflexion porte à la
fois sur les fonctionnaires d'État qui
étaient concernés mais aussi sur les
deux autres fonctions publiques merci
merci beaucoup monsieur le ministre
merci beaucoup monsieur le député
sur la retraite progressive je peux vous
confirmer de manière très simple qu'elle
concerne bien les trois versants de la
fonction publique bien entendu qui me
semble que l'enjeu fondamental pour un
dispositif qui est encore une fois je
veux insister une seconde là-dessus
attractif et qui me semble contrairement
à ce que je peux entendre parfois même
plus attractif que les dispositif de
cessation progressive d'activité mais
passons et on aura peut-être l'occasion
de rebondir sa question là l'enjeu
fondamental c'est est-ce que nous en
faisons réellement un instrument
d'aménagement des carrières que nous
inscrivons au cœur de nos politiques RH
sur la fonction publique c'est la raison
pour laquelle j'ai réuni il y a quelques
jours les secrétaires généraux ainsi que
les DRH des différents ministères que
ce sont des sujets que nous avons mis en
discussion avec les amplleurs
territoriaux et les employeurs
hospitaliers pour justement inscrire
pour de vrai pas pour en faire des
droits de papier mais pour en faire des
droits réels de ce dispositif de
retraite progressive un vrai outil
d'aménagement des parcours
professionnels parce que on peut
effectivement se mettre à temps partiel
à la fin d'une carrière peut-être
transmettre il y a dans la territoriale
par exemple des enjeux de transmission
de formation qui sont très importants je
pense au secrétaire de mairie par
exemple on pourrait imaginer des
dispositifs ou on aménage les fins de
carrière des agents publics pour
peut-être à temps partiel transmettre
formés et je crois que ça fait partie
évidemment des transformations et des
réformes que nous devons apporter
ensuite sur les dispositifs ultramarins
je vous réponds de façon très simple que
nous ne remettons en cause aucune des
clauses particulières des bonifications
particulières pour les agents publics
ultramarins et donc il y a pour
reprendre votre expression aucun
dispositif qui passe à la trappe ça
c'est extrêmement clair il y a une
problématique particulière que vous avez
évoquée autour de l'indemnité temporaire
de retraite autour de l'ither pour
rappel collectif c'est un dispositif qui
a été mis en place en 2008 qui a été
souvent discuté mais remis en cause par
aucun gouvernement qui prévoit une
dégressivité d'un mécanisme dérogatoire
qui permettait à des agents publics qui
avaient travaillé dans un territoire
ultramarin ou qui n'avait pas travailler
dans un territoire ultramarin deux
bénéficier d'une bonification de pension
de retraite dans le cas où il
s'installait au moment de leur retraite
dans un territoire ultramarin ce qui est
vrai c'est que nous devons avoir une
réflexion sur les mécanismes
compensatoire par rapport à cette
ITER qui est progressivement mis en
extinction c'est l'engagement qui avait
été pris par le gouvernement qui a réuni
un comité de travail qui s'est réunit
une première fois dans le quinquennat
précédent et que conformément à nos
engagements nous avons réuni à nouveau
il y a quelques jours c'était je crois
le 17 février
sous l'égide ministère des outre-mer et
l’intérieur enfin l'intérêt des
outre-mer et les ministère de la
transformation de la fonction publique
pour travailler avec les parlementaires
sur les mécanismes compensatoire qui
doivent répondre justement à la Ferté de
la vie dans les territoires ultramants
deux engagements un de qualifier
justement la charte de la vie de
qualifier l'enjeu de financement
complémentaire ou compensatoire que nous
devons avoir et deux un engagement de
temporalité l'engagement que nous avons
pris Jean-François caraco et moi-même
c'est d'aboutir sur ces mécanismes et
sur ces discussions avec des réflexions
autour de mécanismes sur cotisation
facultatif pour les agents publics d'ici
le projet de loi de finances 2024
c'est-à-dire d'ici l'automne pour
prendre et tenir les engagements de
l'État sur cette question là merci
monsieur le ministre a vraiment essayé
de se cantonner à deux minutes si
possible pour la suite sinon je vais
créer un précédent et je vois que
Monsieur
tu avais déjà fait
la parole est à Monsieur Je Frédéric
carolier pour le compresse ment national
merci
Monsieur le Ministre on a quand même
l'impression que pour maintenir votre
totem de recul de l'âge légal de 62 à 64
ans si je voulais être des obligeant je
dirais vous lâchez en tout cas vous
donnez beaucoup on le voit au travers de
la fonction publique vous avez parlé de
des cinq améliorations
vous avez rappelé pour être dans la
protection sociale un peu plus large que
vous êtes en cours de signature sur la
complémentaire santé dans la fonction
publique d'État et que un des objectifs
c'est la prévoyance de collective enfin
fonction publique d'État
alors l'objet de cette réforme c'était
de faire des des économies sur la
branche retraite bon tout le monde a
compris que
les retraites les retraités servaient de
variables d'ajustement pour faire
baisser les déficits publics et pour
repasser à l'horizon de 202 sous les
fameux 3% du critère
européen le déficit public sur les 3% du
PIB monsieur Moscovici nous en avait
parlé monsieur Brun nous avait bien
expliqué tout cela donc à l'arrivée la
question les deux questions que je
voudrais vous poser à combien donc vous
chiffrez aujourd'hui les économies que
vous envisagez envisagez de faire avec
le recul donc de l'âge légal dans donc
dans la fonction publique et donc
l'accélération de la loi Touraine et la
deuxième question
ça concerne combien de fonctionnaires ce
que vous pouvez nous donner des chiffres
par fonction publique des tas
territorial et hospitalière
merci
je prends votre première élément
d'intervention comme un complément
puisque vous notez que abandon
d'amélioration a été de notre système de
retraite pour la fonction publique qui
sont pas du tout des compensations de
quoi que ce soit moi je l'ai d'ailleurs
jamais présenté tel quel aux
organisations syndicales mais qui sont
des réels améliorations de notre
disputif de retraite toutes les
insistent sur ce point là au sujet de
l'aménagement des carrières et la
possibilité que nous avons d'aménager
soit le temps de travail soit les
conditions même de l'exercice de sa
fonction dans la fonction publique soit
de pouvoir changer de métier dans la
fonction publique ça peut arriver aussi
et donc moi je présente de façon
transparente et les efforts qui sont
demandés et les améliorations du système
qui sont permise et apportées par ce
projet de réforme des retraites que vous
avez eu à examiner il y a quelques jours
les économies tout ceci est inscrit dans
le l'étude d'impact pour la fonction
publique c'est 2,5 milliards euros sur
les
17,5 18 milliards d'euros au global
d'économie qui sont apportées par le
projet de présenter par le gouvernement
donc 2,5 milliards d'euros les
différents dispositifs qui viennent
améliorer notre système sont pas du tout
comparables à la hauteur puisque c'est
autour de 330 millions d'euros chiffrés
pour la fonction publique pour
l'instauration d'un mécanisme de
retraite progressive par exemple
l'amélioration de la portabilité des
droits pour les catégories actives les
mesures que je présentais d'amélioration
de dispositif pour les contractuels si
tu la résonnes à la fonction publique ou
encore l'instauration d'un fonds de
prévention de l'usure et de la
pénibilité donc voici pour les grands
équilibres dans le périmètre fonction
publique de la réforme des retraites qui
vous est proposé à cette examen elle
concerne je l'ai dit les 5,7 millions
d'agents de la fonction publique qui
soit contractuelle ou qui soit titulaire
c'est à dire fonctionnaire dans la
fonction publique il y a aujourd'hui 20%
de contractuels pour 80% de titulaires
dans les trois versants de la fonction
publique qui sont répartis mais c'est
assez classique et c'est des chiffres
qui sont disponibles autour de 2,2
millions d'agents pour la fonction
publique d'État un peu plus de 1 million
d'agents je pars sous le contrôle de mon
cabinet pour la fonction publique
territoriale et à peu près les mêmes
nombres d'agents pour la fonction
publique hospitalière peut-être avec le
temps qui met un parti en profiter pour
préciser que pour la fonction publique
les titulaires donc les fonctionnaires
cotisent à un système de retraite
spécifique à la fonction publique les
contractuels sont au régime général et
ont une complémentaire qui l'Ircantec
donc il y a deux systèmes qui sont un
peu différents pour les contractuels ou
pour les titulaires mais les
modifications apporteront de façon
symétrique sur les contractuels et les
titulaires voilà pour la réponse
[Musique]
sur quelque chose qui a été évoqué tout
à l'heure par les organisations à la
table ronde notamment leur crainte de
voir le passage en mise en concurrence
des complémentaires non seulement
remettre en cause ce que le mutualisme
français a construit pendant des
décennies mais aussi voir que n'étant
pas retenu lors de mise en concurrence
il pourrait très bien se retrouver avec
des retraités et finalement plus de
cotisants actifs en face donc ma
question est en la matière confrontée à
cette crainte et à cette interpellation
de leur part comment pensez-vous
appréhender cette question pour
des mutuelles qui ne se verraient pas
retenu par ces procédures dans un champ
concurrentiel pour lequel moi je ne
partage pas qu'il faudrait et qu'il faut
impérativement l'ouvrir à la concurrence
puisque on pourrait très bien se
soustraire à ce que on imagine être
contraint par la Commission européenne
et ma dernière question porte sur le
fait que le 27 janvier comme d'autres et
notamment par les employeurs de la
fonction publique
territoriales et hospitalière nous avons
été stupéfés par ce qui a été avancé
comme relèvement de 1% dans de 1 point
des cotisations de retraite des
employeurs territoriaux et hospitaliers
comment imaginez-vous que les
collectivités qui subissent déjà des
dépenses de fonctionnement croissante
notamment en matière d'énergie vont
pouvoir faire face à une telle situation
pensez-vous
qu'il est prévoyez-vous une compensation
financière en avançant sur cette piste
là ou alors est-ce finalement le retour
du pacte de Cahors sans le nommer
merci Monsieur le Ministre trois sujets
je vais essayer d'apporter des réponses
les plus complètes mais concises
possibles 1 sur le besoin de
fonctionnaire d'agent de la fonction
publique dans les trois versants il est
clair je parle avec un mandat de
ministre de la transformation et de la
fonction publique qui ne repose pas sur
des suppressions de poste dans la
fonction publique ça vous a pas échappé
et d'ailleurs le quinquennat précédent a
été un quinquennat de stabilité d'emploi
pour la fonction publique en nombre de
fonctionnaires ce qui était d'ailleurs
pas le programme qui avait été présenté
en 2017 puisqu'il reposait sur 120 000
sous pression de postes en l'occurrence
les crises et notamment la crise
sanitaire nous a fait revoir ce
programme-là et en 2022 le président de
la République candidat n'a pas présenté
un programme consistant à supprimer des
postes dans la fonction publique au
contraire et pour ne pas être trop long
je veux pas reprendre les
investissements dans les services
publics que nous menons aujourd'hui dans
différents domaines la justice l'école
la santé par exemple deuxième sujet sur
la CNRACL là-dessus je vais répondre de
façon très claire puisque nous avons
réuni à plusieurs reprises ces derniers
jours les employeurs territoriaux avec
Dominique Faure ainsi qu'avec Gabriel
Attal et nous avons acté une
compensation intégrale des hausses de
cotisation de la cnr-a-cl qui verra ses
déficits se creuser là aussi pour des
raisons démographiques pour beaucoup
dans les années qui viennent le déficit
de la caisse spécifique aux employeurs
hospitaliers et territoriaux mais
contrairement aux deux hausse de
cotisations précédentes qui avaient été
portées par des majorités précédentes
nous avons pris l'engagement d'une
compensation intégrale ce qui n'avait
jamais été acté à ce stade et donc je
crois que on peut dire que on a un
dialogue de confiance avec les
employeurs territoriaux et je crois pas
les les sous-entendus que vous portez
dans votre question et ensuite mais à
chaque fois il reste trop peu de temps
pour aborder cette question vraiment
capital pour moi les enjeux autour de la
prévoyance c'est pas un enjeu qui serait
conduit par Bruxelles ou de mise en
concurrence idéologique c'est un enjeu
d'amélioration de la couverture et de la
protection des agents de la fonction
publique voilà ce qui moi ministre de la
Fonction publique manime et m'intéresse
je vois qu'aujourd'hui il y a une hétéro
dégénérité extrêmement importante de
protection des élans de la fonction
publique entre ceux avec parfois des
politiques historiques et des liens avec
certaines mutuelles historiques avec
certains ministères avec certaines
collectivités par exemple ça peut
exister ou les agents sont couverts et
puis il y en a d'autres où il y a rien
du tout et donc moi je pense à jeunes
femmes qui découvre qu'elle a par
exemple un cancer du sein je pense un
couple qui voit un conjoint décédé et
donc qui découvre à ce moment-là que
leur protection parce qu'ils n'ont pas
de mutuelle complémentaires et
extrêmement mauvaises si on s'en tient à
la seule protection statutaire et donc
moi l'enjeu que j'ai c'est d'améliorer
la protection
la discussion que nous avons c'est
est-ce que ça se fait à travers du tout
statutaire c'est à dire l'employeur
public assume le risque et qui protège
mais dans ce cas là ça se fera
éventuellement au détriment des acteurs
qui soient mutualistes ou assurantiel
d'ailleurs ou est-ce qu'on le fait avec
une part de
d'assurantielle c'est-à-dire en faisant
appel à des spécialistes à des acteurs
mutualistes ou assurentiels pour couvrir
le risque et mieux prévenir mais en tout
cas avec un seul axe et je termine
là-dessus qui sera d'améliorer la
couverture prévoyance des agents de la
fonction publique merci
oui c'est inconvénient de poser
plusieurs questions dans la question ça
finit par faire s'allonger les débats
mais c'est intéressant évidemment
la parole est à Monsieur Francis Dubois
pour le groupe les républicains
oui monsieur le ministre ma question
porte sur les carrières
je souhaite vous interroger sur le
statut des secrétaires de mairie dans
les petites communes notamment en milieu
rural maillon essentiel incontournable
de la vie communale les secrétaires de
mairie sont l'appuis technique et
juridique des maires et participe comme
vous le savez à la mise en oeuvre des
politiques de l'équipe municipale c'est
un emploi qui nécessite compétences
multiples finances gestion des services
techniques ressources humaines
urbanisme préparation des conseils
municipaux gestion de l'état civil
organisation des exceptions accueille au
public etc le secteur le secrétaire de
mairie doit ainsi faire preuve d'une
grande adaptabilité de polyvalence et
d'organisation et ce d'autant plus en
milieu rural comme en Corrèze ou très
souvent plusieurs communes se partagent
même secrétaire de mairie cependant
malgré un profil très complet un rôle
décisif dans la bonne tenue de la vie de
la commune la reconnaissance de cette
fonction dépend en adéquation avec les
dispositions statutaires actuelles les
missions sont mal définies les agents
sur le départ sont systématiquement
remplacés par des agents administratifs
de catégorie C titulaire ou contractuel
et le protocole parcourt professionnel
carrière et rémunération
permettant une refonte des grilles des
salaires n'a pas pu bénéficier au
secrétaire de mairie devant la nécessité
de mieux connaître ce métier dans un
contexte actuel de tension sur les
effectifs et de vieillissement des
agents une récente proposition de loi
transpartisienne initié par notre
collègue Pierre Morel à l'huissier et à
laquelle j'ai apporté ma consignature
vise à revaloriser le métier ce texte
propose de faire évoluer l'appellation
de la profession en responsable de
l'administration communale et de créer
un statut d'emploi comprenant deux
grilles indiciaires il propose également
pour pallier aux difficultés de
recrutement d'élargir la possibilité
pour les communes de recruter des agents
contractuels en relevant le plafond
démographique en deçà duquel se
recrutement est ouvert de 1000 à 2000
habitants il envisage aussi la mise en
oeuvre en lien avec le CNFPT de
formation spécifique
dont une au titre de la prise de poste
ces formations sur un effet très utile
en particulier pour les contractuels
recrutés en conséquent je vous demande
monsieur le ministre si un écho a cette
initiative parlementaire soutenu sur le
terrain votre ministère entend
prochainement prendre des décisions en
vue d'assurer une peine reconnaissance à
ce métier je vous remercie
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre
merci à vous monsieur le député il y a
pas je crois un jour en tant que
cuisiner la fonction publique sans dans
lequel je ne parle pas des secrétaires
de mairie parce que c'est un enjeu qui
est capital
singulièrement pour les communes rurales
et plus la taille de la commune est
petite j'irai plus l'importance de sa
secrétaire de mairie et absolument
décisive j'écoutume de dire que une
secrétaire qui part à la retraite et qui
n'est pas remplacée c'est comme si on
fermait une maison un espace France
service en réalité vu l'expérience
acquise et qui est portée parfois pour
plusieurs communes puisque les
secrétaires de mairie ont parfois la
caractéristique d'avoir des
polymployeurs et de partager leur temps
entre différentes collectivités deuxième
point d'accord c'est l'enjeu là aussi de
d'attractivité de remplacement des
secrétaires d'Amérique qui partent à la
retraite il y a dans les 8 prochaines
années environ un tiers des secrétaires
américains qui vont partir à la retraite
donc on a cet enjeu qui est un enjeu
absolument partagé c'est pas vrai de
dire que rien n'a été fait dans le
quinquennat précédent il y a eu un
dispositif de NBI qui a apporté 15
points de revalorisation indiciaire pour
les secrétaires de mairie est-ce que ça
a été suffisant et pour sol de tout
compte pour relever le défi
d'attractivité sur ce métier la réponse
est non mais je me devais évidemment de
façon complète de donner ces éléments
ensuite ce qui est fondamental dans
votre question c'est est-ce qu'on va
faire des choses oui la réponse est
évidemment dans le cadre de la réforme
que je porterai en 2023 que je mets en
discussion avec les organisations
syndicales sur l'accès les parcours et
la rémunération je veux faire des
secrétaires de mairie un démonstrateur
de ce que nous pouvons faire de positif
en matière d'attractivité et je pense
qu'il faut toucher aux trois leviers
possibilité de recrutement sur l'accès
là aussi je veux lever un certain nombre
de contraintes parce que vous évoquez
comme piste me semble tout à fait
intéressant et je les mettrai en
discussion je pense qu'on doit davantage
raisonner en termes de valorisation des
acquis de l'expérience d'expérience
professionnelle et parfois
un tout petit peu moins sur le
formalisme certains concours pour
pouvoir justement bénéficier de
l'expérience sur état de mairie sur
l'aspect des parcours je ne me résous
pas à des carrières qui sont parfois
trop linéaires et donc je veux donner là
aussi plus d'éléments de marge de
manœuvre aux employeurs pour pouvoir
faire progresser plus rapidement des
secrétaires de mairie quand les
employeurs envoient l'opportunité et
puis enfin je conclu là-dessus madame
présidente sur la possibilité aussi dans
le cadre d'une réflexion sur les
parcours de pouvoir évoluer et parfois
même en sortant du seul parcours de
secrétaire de mairie pourquoi ne pas
devenir DGS par exemple dans une autre
collectivité de taille les plus
importantes ce sont les possibilités que
je souhaite développer nous aurons je
crois et j'espère l'occasion d'en
reparler à l'occasion de la réforme que
je porterai sur l'Axel et parcours et la
rémunération dans la fonction publique
merci je n'ai pas d'autres questions
monsieur le Président Chassaigne et
Monsieur vous êtes pas signal et
messieurs
alors très bien alors monsieur le
Président Chassaigne et puis
il faudrait des heures pour répondre
sans doute à la question que je vous
posais donc je vais essayer de la
réduire au maximum ça m'empêche
pratiquement de dormir pour quelle
raison avez-vous fait appel un cabinet
de conseil pour la protection sociale
complémentaire si c'est le cas et est-ce
que par exemple vous avez interrogé sur
les risques inhérents à la
marchandisation il y a une question dans
ce sens tout à l'heure vous avez répondu
si j'ai bien compris notamment sur
l'enjeu d'amélioration de la protection
ça a pas été très convaincant est-ce que
par exemple vous avez demandé des études
sur les conséquences de la suppression
des régimes spéciaux avec l'inégalité
les injustices que ça a provoqué entre
les recrutés au statut et nouveaux
entrants sur un appel qui sera beaucoup
plus large à des retraits de
complémentaires par exemple les
assurances privées ou à des mutuelles ou
est-ce que par exemple vous avez demandé
quelle une étude précise sur l'évolution
de la prise en compte de l'invalidité
pour les fonctionnaires
et acquis en fait sont mis en retraite
contrairement à retraite avec les
conséquences que ça contrairement à ce
qui se passe dans le privé est-ce que
toutes ces réflexions là
vous vous êtes à même d'apporter des
réponses peut-être à la suite du travail
qui a pu être fait pas gratuitement par
un cabinet de conseil
merci Monsieur le Ministre merci
monsieur le président
est-ce qu'il est légitime pour l'état de
se faire accompagner sur des sujets
aussi complexes et techniques que ceux
des dispositifs de prévoyance je vous
réponds sans détour la réponse c'est oui
je pense au contraire qui serait assez
irresponsable de la part de l'état de
travailler à des sujets qui sont aussi
impliquant dans lesquels les
conséquences pour la protection des
agents ainsi que pour les finances
publiques sont aussi lourdes sans
travailler non pas avec des cabinets de
conscience stratégie telles qu'on peut
les trouver sur d'autres types de
dossiers mais tout simplement des
actuaires pour pouvoir chiffrer les
différentes pistes qui sont mises en
discussion avec les organisations
syndicales et donc c'est exactement
comme ça de façon très transparente que
le gouvernement peut travailler et je
crois que c'est au contraire à la fois
de la bonne gestion de nos finances
publiques et pour préparer des bons
choix pour nos agents publics deuxième
élément dans quel état d'esprit nous
travaillons avec quels enjeux nous
travaillons sur ces questions là je le
dis et je le redis dans un état d'esprit
d'amélioration de la protection des
agents de la fonction publique en
partant d'un constat que je ne reprends
pas ici c'est à dire d'un mécanisme de
protection qui est extrêmement
hétérogène à minima puisque entre les
agents qui sont couverts par des
complémentaires ou ceux qui n'ont pas
couverts des complémentaires il y a des
différences de protection sociale qui
sont abyssales et des agents qui ne sont
pas suffisamment bien couverts et qui
parfois n'en sont même pas suffisamment
conscient et donc l'objectif porté par
ce gouvernement et qui était conforme à
l'accord de méthodes qui je le rappelle
a été unanime moins forte ouvrière si je
dis pas de bêtises c'est d'aboutir un
dispositif de protection sociale
complémentaire sur la prévoyance qui
permettent de couvrir l'ensemble des
agents de la fonction publique dans un
objectif de couverture des trois
versants de la fonction publique en
amélioration de la protection actuelle
qui n'est que statutaire c'est à dire
que aujourd'hui les dispositifs ces
dispositifs d'auto-assurance par
l'employeur public et si ce n'est de
façon complémentaire c'est-à-dire au
seul coup pour les agents s'ils prennent
une mutuelle en complémentaire et qui
couvre effectivement souvent de façon
conjointe les risques santé et les
risques prévoyance et donc je souhaite
améliorer et ça sera le cas des
discussions que nous avons avec les
organisations syndicales sur les trois
sujets de l'invalidité de l'incapacité
et du décès la couverture des agents
publics je dis un mot madame présente
pour ne pas laisser le présent en
chassen trop frustré sur la question
notamment de l'invalidité il y a deux
enjeux il y a un enjeu d'intégration des
trimestres par la suite quand les agents
sont à la retraite et un enjeu de
couverture quand un agent la fonction
publique est touchée par l'invalidité et
c'est bien sur ces deux enjeux là que je
souhaite qu'on puisse avancer et aboutir
c'est mon objectif en tout cas avec les
organisations syndicales
merci monsieur le ministre et la
dernière question sera posée par
Monsieur Gérard le seul pour le groupe
socialiste merci madame la Présidente je
remercie le groupe FEDER d'avoir mis
cette question à l'ordre du jour et mon
groupe souhaite tout d'abord vous
questionner monsieur le ministre sur
l'appauvrissement des retraités issus de
la fonction publique que votre texte
prévoit d'aggraver ce phénomène
d'appauvrissement s'illustrer
essentiellement pour les fonctionnaires
avec le taux de remplacement
c'est-à-dire le ratio entre le montant
de la retraite perçu à la liquidation et
le salaire versé juste avant de partir à
la retraite précisons que selon le
Conseil d'orientation de retraite ce
taux est aujourd'hui inférieur à celui
des salariés du secteur privé cela
signifie concrètement ta carrière et
salaire égale la pension du
fonctionnaire est plus faible que celle
d'un salarié du secteur privé selon
notre lecture du rapport du corps de
septembre 2022 le gouvernement prévoit
non pas de mettre fin à cette injustice
mais bien de l'aggraver en effet dans
les hypothèses macro économique
transmise au corps il prévoit un gel du
point d'indice jusqu'en 2027 ainsi
qu'une stabilité de la part des primes
dans la rémunération pour un
fonctionnaire donc payé 2000 euros net
par mois en 2022 ce gel du point
d'indice jusqu'en 2027 représente très
une perte de pouvoir d'achat d'environ
11000 euros sur tout le quinquennat le
gouvernement réalise là un virage
discret mais grave par rapport aux
hypothèses transmises au corps en 2021
ce gel va mécaniquement faire baisser le
pouvoir de vivre des futurs retraités de
la fonction publique ainsi quel que soit
le scénario envisagé le corps estime que
le taux de remplacement pour les agents
publics baissera de dos à de 2 à 10
points dans les prochaines années dès
lors le gouvernement peut-il le
confirmer à la représentation nationale
qu'il compte geler le point d'indice
jusqu'en 2027 avec tous les impacts
qu'aura cette décision comptable sur les
pensions des retraités issues de la
fonction publique ensuite mon groupe
souhaiterait obtenir une précision que
l'étude d'impact jouant à la réforme des
retraites n'apporte pas vous estimez
dans celle ci que la pension moyenne
tout régime confondu après la réforme
sera supérieure à celle avant la réforme
pourriez-vous nous préciser les montants
précis de pension moyenne avant après
réforme pour des fonctionnaires en
tenant compte du fait que le décalage de
l'âge légal de départ à la retraite va
annuler la surcote donc bénéficier
certains agents publics et enfin vous
avez évoqué la retraite progressive à
compter de 62 ans j'ai quelques
inquiétudes sur sa réussite mais nous
serons vigilants je vous remercie
monsieur le ministre de répondre au
moins aux deux premières questions
merci Monsieur le seul monsieur le
ministre merci beaucoup et je le dis ce
qu'on trouve à présente je me rendez pas
la tâche facile dans cet exercice de
répondre en deux minutes à quand même
beaucoup de questions que vous posez
dans chacune 1 j'ai mentionné moi-même
le comparatif de taux de remplacement
entre le privé et le public dans mon
propos liminaire on était il est très
comparable à 0,6% près similaire entre
le public et le privé la réalité c'est
que en fonction de la structuration de
la rémunération des différentes
catégories d'agents publics c'est-à-dire
est-ce qu'il y a beaucoup d'indemnités
dans leur rémunération ou pas c'est ça
qui fait une différence de taux de
remplacement dans la fonction publique
et donc on est situation qui est plutôt
hétérogène une étude récente montrait
que le basculement dans le régime privé
faisait des gagnants et des perdants au
sein des fonctionnaires ce qui rendait
d'ailleurs la réforme de 2019 parfois on
se gêne pour certaines catégories de
fonctionnaires elle est un petit peu
moins pour cette réforme que nous
portons en 2023
la réalité c'est que la question de taux
de remplacement elle est fondée sur la
rémunération des agents de la fonction
publique et notamment l'évolution la
rémunération indiciaire je peux le dire
en regardant la représentation nationale
droit dans les yeux puisque je suis le
ministre la fonction publique qui a le
plus augmenté le point d'indice de ces
37 dernières années on l'augmentant
l'année dernière le 3,5%. je le dis au
passage beaucoup plus que un gel du
point d'indice qui concernait les
quinquennat précédent le premier
quinquennat de cette majorité actuelle
mais aussi le quinquennat du président
Hollande du président Sarkozy le gel du
point d'indice un gel qui est antérieur
et donc cette majorité a plus augmenté
le point d'indice que toutes les
majorités précédentes ces dernières
années ce qu'il y a effectivement un
impact sur les pensions de retraite à
venir ça c'était le premier point
ensuite vous mentionnez les hypothèses
qui ont été transmises au corps
simplement parce que vous conviendrez
qu'il était de faire des prévisions sur
l'inflation à venir qui a beaucoup bougé
c'est derniers mois et donc il est
difficile de faire une prédiction pour
les mois à venir ces hypothèses dans
l'étude d'impact du texte retraite elle
ne valent pas pour les discussions que
j'ai et que nous allons continuer à
avoir avec les organisations syndicales
nous faisons face à nouveau à une année
d'inflation importante et moi j'ai tenu
une position claire vis-à-vis des
organisations syndicales que j'exprime
ici de façon transparente devant la
représentation nationale ni évité les
discussions sur le pouvoir d'achat et la
conjoncture et l'inflation ni dissocier
les discussions que nous avons sur la
rémunération sur l'enjeu de rémunération
des agents de la fonction publique elles
devront intégrer la situation
conjoncturelle le niveau d'inflation
auquel nous faisons face mais je
souhaite qu'on puisse mener une réforme
des rémunérations dans la fonction
publique je pense qu'elle est
essentielle m'avait interrogé sur les
évolutions de carrière que l'on peut
donner à des agents de la fonction
publique en interrogeant par exemple sur
les secrétaires de mairie moi je
souhaite qu'on puisse conduire une
réflexion une discussion et des des
concertations avec des organisations
syndicales sur la structure de
rémunération sur l'évolution des
carrières que l'on peut donner et c'est
pour ça que je dis ni dissocier je veux
mener cette réflexion structurelle sur
la rémunération ni évitez c'est-à-dire
que nous prendrons en compte pour les
mois à venir aussi la situation de
l'inflation et donc je continuerai
d'avoir cette discussion dans le cadre
des conférences salariales avec les
organisations syndicales
merci monsieur le ministre et merci cher
collègue le débat est clos merci à
prochaine séance ce soir à 21h45 des va
sur le thème hyper concentration des
dépenses du ministère de la Culture en
Île-de-France une fatalité point
d'interrogation la séance est levée